Hey everyone, we're here with Benji, the co-founder and CEO of Shipyard. His expertise, let's say, is something a little bit further away from mine than normal. So I'm kind of excited about this. Always a great opportunity to learn something new in the field of software and engineering. It's a big field. And I think the stuff we're going to talk about today is something that, you know, for me, at least I studied, you know, programming in college, you have a CS degree. And when I was there, you very get in a very skewed view of how software development works. You're like one person or two people team, you think you got it figured out. And then you show up in your first job. And
大家好，我们今天请到了 Shipyard 的联合创始人兼首席执行官 Benji。他的专业领域，怎么说呢，比我平时接触的要稍微远一点。所以我其实挺兴奋的。这总是一个在软件和工程领域学习新知识的好机会。这是一个很大的领域。我觉得我们今天要聊的内容，对我来说，至少我在大学里学过编程，你有个计算机科学学位。当时在学校里，你对软件开发工作方式的看法是非常偏颇的。你会觉得自己是一人或两人团队，觉得你已经搞懂了。然后你走进第一份工作。结果呢，
there's, you know, dozens of people on on the team and everything you thought you knew about how the world worked is just wrong. And so I think a little bit today, we're going to understand how in the real world, some of the complexities of building software happen and as well as even past that. And so happy to have Benji here. Welcome to the show. Hey, thanks for having me. So let's start, at least I traditionally like to start off by saying, what was your sort of first experience with getting into development or programming or tech in general?
团队里有几十个人，而你之前关于世界运转方式的所有认知全都是错的。所以我想今天我们稍微了解一下，在现实世界中，构建软件的一些复杂性是如何发生的，甚至还有超越这部分的内容。很高兴 Benji 能来到这里。欢迎来到节目。嘿，谢谢邀请我。那我们开始吧，至少我习惯性的开场白是，你进入开发、编程或整个科技领域的最初经历是什么？
Do you have like a formative moment? If not, I mean, that's okay too. Yeah, I think my formative moment was when my dad did something, I can't remember what it was, to my Commodore 64 so that I couldn't play the archery game. And I somehow figured, I can't remember what it was, but I just remember I figured out how to get around something by typing a bunch of stuff. And there was definitely no Google in the day. So I was very proud of that accomplishment. And basically, I caught the bug at a very, very, very young age of being like, Oh, wow, like everybody's equal in the digital world, you just have to figure out the best. And so I would say that's when I really started. And then it probably took off a little bit more. And I will say that I
你有什么决定性的时刻吗？如果没有，其实也没关系。对，我觉得我的决定性时刻是我爸对我的康多猫 64（Commodore 64）做了点什么，我不记得是什么了，导致我玩不了射箭游戏。我不知怎么琢磨出来的，我不记得具体怎么回事了，但我只记得我通过输入一堆东西弄清楚了如何绕过某种限制。当时绝对没有谷歌。所以我对这个成就感到非常自豪。基本上，我在非常、非常、非常小的年纪就染上了这种“病毒”，觉得：“哇，在数字世界里人人平等，你只需要找出最好的方法就行。”所以我想这就是我真正开始的时候。然后它可能就发展得更多了。而且我要说的是，我
am officially, I'm not a millennial. I'm not a, what's the other one? Yeah, I am. I'm an Oregon trails generation. I don't know if you guys have ever heard that term, but I think, Oh my gosh, the game's amazing. Yeah. So if you know the game, yeah, exactly. If you are worried about dysentery and you're hunting squirrels, then you are in this in-between generational thing. Now, did you play the Apple one or the one on Windows where you could click to shoot the squirrels? So I played, so in my day, I did play a little bit of the really early Apple one, but that was because my mom was an art teacher and she got us a free old Apple IIc like 10 years
官方来说，我不是千禧一代。我也不是，另一个是什么来着？对，我是。我是“俄勒冈之旅（Oregon Trail）”这一代人。我不知道你们有没有听过这个词，但我当时想，天哪，这游戏太棒了。对。所以如果你知道这个游戏，对，没错。如果你担心痢疾还在猎杀松鼠，那你就是处于这种夹在中间的一代。话说回来，你玩的是苹果（Apple）版，还是能在 Windows 上点击射松鼠的那个版本？我玩的是，在我那个年代，我确实玩过一点很早期的 Apple 版本，但那是因为我妈是个美术老师，她给我们弄到了一台免费的旧 Apple IIc，大约是在
after they got them out of the classrooms. I don't know. Someone was like throwing them out and they have a computer kid but in school i played the there was like an early macintosh one so i think technically i was playing oregon trails 2 um very on topic for this podcast by the way oh yeah this is so pertinent um i'm glad that we could go through that you gotta have a shared history with people. It's all right. Yeah. It's good. It's good. And then,
它们退出课堂 10 年后。我不知道。有人把它们扔掉，它们有一台电脑小孩，但在学校里我玩的是，有一种早期的麦金塔（Macintosh）版本，所以我技术上觉得我玩的是《俄勒冈之旅 2》嗯，顺便说一句，这非常契合这个播客的主题哦，对，这太切题了，我很高兴我们能聊到这个，你得和别人有共同的历史。没关系。对。很好，很好。然后呢，
so how did you kind of end up, I mean, now, now this is your, you know, kind of your career and your entire, I mean, did you go to school to study engineering or programming or what did your, what's your kind of path take?
你是怎么走到这一步的——我是说，现在这成了你的职业和你的全部，我是说，你上学是去学工程或编程了吗，还是你的经历经历了怎样的路径？
Yeah. So I actually ended up going to a UC Irvine computer science school and I studied computer science there. And I did not realize it at the time, but I had a spectacular education. And I really learned a lot. And one of the things I'd highlight, because obviously, I've worked in this field for some time, and I have a lot of some of the probably my smartest friends are ones that have not gone to school. There's probably some exceptions to that, but, or the most effective engineers that I know at the very least. But I will say that for me going to school, it gave me some foundational stuff that I use every single day in every single
对。所以我最后去了加州大学欧文分校（UC Irvine）的计算机科学学院，并在那里学习了计算机科学。当时我并没有意识到，但我受了非常棒的教育。我确实学到了很多东西。我要强调的一点是，因为显然，我这个领域工作了一段时间，我有很多聪明的朋友，其中一些可能是最聪明的朋友根本没上过学。这可能有些例外，或者至少是我所知道的最有经验的工程师。但我要说的是，对我来说上学，它给了我一些基础知识，这些知识我每天都在用，在每一个
conversation around, you know, technical decisions and just understanding, you know, how CPUs work at the very bottom there with assembly language and just all the different trade-offs. I think I learned all of that from computer science school. And I do hate assembly. Don't get me wrong. I really hate Lisp. I really hate Lisp. But I had to- Oh, don't talk about Lisp. Lisp is the way to get lots of feedback on the show. I have to tell you, I haven't listened to the back catalog but i know i know some airline company wrote the reservation system in for in lisp in 1990 and that's why everyone says lisp is a real language it is a real language sorry i don't think it's not a real language but i just all right just to be clear veggie is talking and not jason arise so please send all the mail to him yeah i am the one
关于技术决策的对话中，以及仅仅是理解 CPU 在底层是如何通过汇编语言工作的，还有所有不同的权衡。我想我都是从计算机科学学校学到这些的。我确实讨厌汇编。别误会我。我真的很讨厌 Lisp。我真的很讨厌 Lisp。但我不得不——哦，别谈 Lisp。Lisp 是在节目中获取大量反馈的途径。我得告诉你，我没听过以前的节目，但我知道，我知道某家航空公司在 1990 年用 Lisp 编写了预订系统，这就是为什么每个人都说 Lisp 是一门真正的语言，它是一门真正的语言，抱歉，我不是说它不是一门真正的语言，但我只是——好吧，为了澄清，说话的是 Benji 而不是 Jason，所以请把所有的邮件都发给他。对，我是那个
set no i'm not saying it's not i my issue is is that recursion makes my brain physically hurt and parentheses also make my brain hurt so i just have a double name too yeah you know i feel like i agree with that one of the things that's interesting is excel is so easy which is all about recursion and functional programming but i think you know i was thinking about this the other day this is just i guess very serendipitous know, I was thinking about this the other day. This is just, I guess, very serendipitous. But I was just thinking about and talking with some friends about why is Excel so easy when functional languages are so hard? And one thing that someone pointed out, which I was really interesting, is, you know, with Excel, you see all the intermediate results. Like usually people don't write giant functions.
说——不，我不是说它不是，我的问题是递归让我的大脑感到实体般的疼痛，括号也让我的大脑感到疼痛，所以我只是——名字也有两个，对，你知道，我觉得我同意这一点。有趣的一件事是，Excel 是如此简单，而它完全关乎递归和编程，但我认为，你知道，我前几天在想这个，这只是，我想非常机缘巧合，你知道，我前几天在想这个。这只是，我想非常机缘巧合。但我当时在想，并和一些朋友讨论，为什么 Excel 如此简单，而函数式语言却如此难？有人指出了一点，我觉得非常有意思，你知道，在 Excel 中，你能看到所有的中间结果。通常人们不会写巨大的函数。
They'll have small functions that'll output to cells, and then those cells will go into other cells. And so it's sort of like you're at any point in time, you're like tracing through your program just all the time. And we think that might be why Excel is the only program to really get functional languages to the masses. That's a good point. You know what else you just made me think about also is it's also a GUI.
他们会编写输出到单元格的小函数，然后这些单元格会进入其他单元格。所以这就好像你在任何时间点，都在不断地追踪你的程序。我们认为这可能就是 Excel 成为唯一真正将函数式语言带给大众的程序的原因。说得好。你知道你刚才还让我想到了什么吗，它也是一个图形用户界面（GUI）。
Like there isn't a GUI for Lisp. Or not when I was, I was actually Schema, I think. Yeah, right. But there's no, like you have that immediate feedback with the cells. So there's kind of a GUI for functional in that regard, if that makes sense. I actually wrote my first neural net in Excel and I actually am really good at Excel. So it's ironic that you bring this up because I love Excel or Google Sheets, whatever. Yep. So how did you get from neural networks in Excel to Shipyard?
就像 Lisp 没有图形用户界面一样。或者在我接触的时候，其实我学的是 Scheme，我想。对，没错。但没有，就像你对单元格有那种即时的反馈一样。所以在这方面函数式语言某种程度上有一个图形用户界面，如果这说得通的话。我实际上在 Excel 中写了我的第一个神经网络，而且我实际上非常擅长 Excel。所以你提起这个具有讽刺意味，因为我喜欢 Excel 或谷歌表格，随便哪个。好吧。那么你是怎么从 Excel 中的神经网络走到 Shipyard 的？
We'll use that as a segue. Oh, yeah, that makes sense. Well, that was back in the day, my computer science days. I call out to my professor, Dr. Frost. That was actually his name. I love calling him out. He's a great professor. So yeah, that was my 102 AI class I took a long time ago.
我们就把这个当作过渡吧。哦，对，这说得通。那是在过去，我的计算机科学时期。我要向我的教授 Frost 博士致敬。他的名字其实就是这个。我喜欢点他的名。他是个伟大的教授。所以，对，那是我很久以前上过的 102 人工智能课。
But what ended up happening was I graduated school and I actually did a startup in Los Angeles. This is back in the day when it was just like MySpace, AOL, and my company. And it was actually a language translation company that was using very early neural net stuff. This is a long time ago. It did not work very well. It kind of worked, but it didn't work all the way. For language translation. But the takeaway there was that, to your point, I showed up.
但后来发生的事情是，我大学毕业后，实际上在洛杉矶创办了一家初创公司。那是 MySpace、AOL 和我的公司刚刚兴起的年代。它实际上是一家语言翻译公司，使用了非常早期的神经网络技术。那是很久以前的事了。它运作得不是很好。它有点用，但没有完全起作用。针对语言翻译。但当时的收获是，正如你所说，我出现了。
I had a startup. How do I host this stuff? How do we do all these things? So that started my DevOps journey, let's say. And back then, it was like writing bash scripts for Linode, I believe, I think EC2 wasn't even out, I want to say, but maybe it was just beginning S3 was around. I remember I used S3 back then, and then ended up moving out to New York and doing a bunch of other tech startup stuff, co-founded one or two things. I'm also like VP of engineering. And throughout that entire career, I was always
我有一家初创公司。我如何托管这些东西？我们如何完成所有这些事情？所以这开始了我的 DevOps 之旅，可以说。当时，就像为 Linode 编写 bash 脚本一样，我相信，我觉得当时 EC2 甚至还没出来，我想，或者可能才刚刚开始，S3 已经有了。我记得我当时用过 S3，然后搬到纽约做了很多其他的科技初创公司的事情，联合创办了一两家公司。我也是工程副总裁。在整个职业生涯中，我一直
owning the DevOps responsibilities for my various companies that I was working. That encompassed everything from Puppet, Chef, Ansible, Salt. I mean, then later on dot cloud docker became docker kubernetes terraform the list goes on and on so actually one question there is what made you go the startup route and not go into big tech like microsoft or one of these companies like like what what was your thought process there i mean when i was in my day or in our day maybe you know i was you know i was microsoft was the bad guy back in the day which is crazy to me because microsoft's a good guy now which just it just blows my mind when i think about or maybe there are worse guys you know maybe it's no but i mean but microsoft has ubuntu built into it you turn on windows 10 now and like ubuntu you just click on a button and you're in ubuntu yeah that's very true
负责我所工作的各个公司的 DevOps 职责。这涵盖了从 Puppet、Chef、Ansible、Salt 的一切。我的意思是，后来 dotCloud、Docker 成为了 Docker、Kubernetes、Terraform，名单列之不尽。所以实际上有一个问题，是什么促使你走创业路线，而不是去微软或其中一家大公司这样的巨头？你的心路历程是什么？我的意思是，在我的时代，或者在我们的时代，也许，你知道，我是，微软在当时是个坏家伙，这对我来说很疯狂，因为微软现在是个好家伙，每当我想到这一点，或者也许有更坏的家伙，你知道，也许不是，但我的意思是，微软内置了 Ubuntu，你现在打开 Windows 10，像 Ubuntu，你只需点一下按钮就在 Ubuntu 里了。是的，确实如此。
and that to me i learned that like i haven't used windows in i don't know 10 years 15 years something like that but i learned i was on a friend's computer and i was trying to help them with some docker stuff and i was like can you just like download a virtual machine and give me like Linux or something? And he's like, oh, I have it. I was like, oh, oh, you did. He's like, no, no, it comes with Windows. I was like, what? And so ever since then, I've been like, holy moly, everything's changed. It's great. But yeah, sorry. What was the question? Oh, yeah. The question was like, okay, maybe, you know, look at the ecosystem of big companies. You have Microsoft, you have Google, you have Apple. And you chose
对我来说，我了解到——我不知道有 10 年、15 年没用过 Windows 了，诸如此类。但我了解到，我在一个朋友的电脑上，我试图帮他们搞一些 Docker 的东西，我说：“你能不能就下载一个虚拟机，给我 Linux 或者是别的什么？”他说：“哦，我有。”我说：“哦，哦，你有了。”他说：“不，不，Windows 自带的。”我说：“什么？”从那以后，我就一直在想：“天哪，一切都变了，这太棒了。”但是，对不起。刚才的问题是什么？哦，对。问题是，好吧，也许，你知道，看看大公司的生态系统。你有微软，你有谷歌，你有苹果。而你选择
to forego the giant corporations and go start something like start a startup or go into the startup ecosystem. And so I was wondering what made you go that route? I think that I just kind of have a little bit of, I don't like cushy things i like being challenged i like kind of like clawing and scraping i also you know microsoft didn't recruit me so maybe if they did i would have i don't know i don't think i would have to be honest with you i really did not like microsoft when i graduated school sorry to everybody but i like them now there are probably a few big large tech companies that i probably shouldn't name that i would never work for these days but microsoft's not one of them actually. And they're great in the space that we're in, in the CNCF cloud native world. Microsoft's been awesome lately. I can't
放弃了庞大的公司，去开启一些事情，比如创业或者进入初创公司的生态系统。所以我很好奇是什么让你走了这条路。我想我只是有点，我不太喜欢安逸的东西，我喜欢被挑战，我喜欢那种挣扎和拼搏的感觉。我也，你知道，微软没有招募我，所以也许如果他们招募了我，我也会去，我不知道，老实说，我毕业时真的不喜欢微软。对大家感到抱歉，但我现在挺喜欢他们的。现在可能有一些大型科技公司，我大概不该点名，我这些天是绝对不会去的，但微软实际上不是其中之一。而且在我们所处的 CNCF 云原生世界中，他们表现得很棒。微软最近一直棒极了。我真
believe I'm doing a Microsoft commercial all of a sudden somehow, but anyway. But yeah, no, I think for me personally, I like having the opportunity to contribute across the board. And I think that the more of a corporate career path that you take, the less opportunity you have for being creative and finding things that you're more excited by. There's more risk and there's less financial stability, that's for sure. But that's never been a big issue to me. Yeah, that makes sense. I mean, one thing I noticed... So Patrick... Actually, Patrick, have you ever... We'll jump to you later, but this is my first time working for a company that isn't at least like, I don't know, 50,000 people or something, right? And so one thing I noticed about the startup I'm working
不敢相信我突然莫名其妙地在为微软做广告，不管怎样。但对，不，我认为对我个人而言，我有机会在各个方面做出贡献。而且我认为，你走的职场路线越企业化，你发挥创造力和寻找自己更感兴趣的事物的机会就越少。风险更大，财务稳定性更低，这是肯定的。但这对我来说从来都不是什么大问题。是的，这说得通。我的意思是，我注意到的一件事……所以帕特里克（Patrick）……实际上，帕特里克，你有没有……我们稍后再找你，但这是我第一次在一家规模至少不是，我不知道，5万人左右的公司工作，对吧？所以我注意到我现在工作的这家初创公司的一件事是，公司里的每个人都在做同一件事。我的意思是，即使你在法律部门、财务部门或任何部门，每个人到头来都在努力把一款产品推向市场。我认为这真的是一件我没有料到而且我非常享受的事。我只是享受我交谈的每个人都在做这件事的事实。而不是，哦，这个人试图制造一个带互联网的热气球。而另一个人试图做一个广告
at now is that everyone in the company is working on the same thing. I mean, even if you're in legal or finance or whatever it is, everyone at the end of the day is trying to get one product out the door. And that, I think, is really something I didn't expect that I really enjoy. I just enjoy the fact that everyone I talk to is working on this thing. And it's not, oh, this person is trying to make like a hot air balloon with Internet. And this other person is trying to do an advertising you know you know marketplace and and and so legal is just like you know trying to you know satisfy all these different people and at any given time only one of them really really matters to to all these cross-functional teams and so all of that kind of disappears when you're at a more focused company.
市场，所以法律部门只是试图满足所有这些不同的人，而在任何给定时间，其中只有一个人对所有这些跨职能团队来说才是真正重要的。所以当你处于一个更专注的公司时，所有这些东西都消失了。
Yeah, I've only ever worked at a massive corporation. So this is an experience that I have not yet, not yet have. That's a great observation. Yeah, I mean, I definitely think that when you all are kind of struggling on the same topic, that cool things happen. And so I've really enjoyed that throughout the course of my career. That being said, of struggling on the same topic that cool things happen and so i've really enjoyed that throughout
是的，我只在大型企业工作过。所以这是我还没有、还未曾有过的体验。这是一个极好的观察。是的，我的意思是，我绝对认为当你们都在同一个话题上挣扎时，很酷的事情就会发生。所以我整个职业生涯中一直非常享受这一点。话虽如此，都在同一个话题上挣扎时，很酷的事情就会发生。所以我整个职业生涯中一直非常享受这一点。话虽如此，
the course of my career that being said i never wanted to do a venture-backed company ever again and myself and my co-founder peter we kind of became these high-priced kubernetes devops engineers in the new york mostly in the new york ecosystem also some la companies in james francisco companies and basically to kind of skip a little bit forward to answer your actual question we were basically going around helping companies in their transition from either traditional you know bare metal or some level of vm to to getting onto the container train specifically around the kubernetes and the production stuff and basically a lot of we saw we started seeing a lot of patterns and we kept kind of having to build the same software and And it was very typically, I wrote this, some DevOps engineer wrote a bespoke way to deploy
我再也不想做一家由风投支持的公司了。我和我的联合创始人彼得（Peter）有点变成了纽约生态系统中高薪的 Kubernetes DevOps 工程师，主要在纽约生态系统，也有一些洛杉矶公司和旧金山公司的项目。基本上，为了快进一点来回答你的实际问题，我们基本上是到处去帮助公司完成他们的转型，从传统的裸机或某种虚拟机迁移到容器列车上，特别是围绕 Kubernetes 和生产环境的东西。基本上，我们看到了很多模式，我们不得不一直构建相同的软件。通常情况下，我写了这个，某个 DevOps 工程师为公司里的各个利益相关者（生产环境、预发布环境、可能还有其他一些环境）定制了一种部署
environments themselves for the various stakeholders at the company, production, staging, maybe some other stuff there. That person has gone or that person has moved on or that person is sick and oh my God, my hair's on fire peter benji come save us and then i would get there and be like oh my god this is all done completely wrong i have to redo the whole thing because this is my bespoke version of this but i know what i'm talking about versus this other person and there was actually an instance where we did that move and then we moved on from that company and that same company brought us back because they hired someone that tore out our stuff and we put it back in. So the DevOps space and the SRE space were very opinionated. But the problem is that there's just way too many options. And consulting shop forever. We kind of built our internal tool, which Shipyard, the first iteration of it was like kind of an exoskeleton for us to rapidly support people. Some of our customers ended up seeing,
环境的方法。那个人走了，或者那个人换工作了，或者那个人生病了，天哪，我的头发着火了，彼得、本ji，快来救救我们。然后我到了那里就会想，天哪，这完全做错了，我得把整个重做一遍，因为这是我对这个东西的定制版本，但我知道我在说什么，而另另一个家伙……实际上有过这样一个例子，我们完成了那种迁移，然后我们离开了那家公司，同一家公司又把我们请了回去，因为他们雇了一个把我们的东西拆了的人，然后我们又把东西装了回去。所以 DevOps 领域和 SRE 领域非常有主见。但问题是选项实在太多了。作为一个永远的咨询店。我们构建了自己的内部工具，Shipyard 的第一个迭代版本就像是我们快速支持人们的外骨骼。我们的一些客户最终看到了，
literally seeing these not very good looking interfaces and like, hey, can we click that button? We're like, yeah, sure. So then we started doing that. Then all of a sudden, we kind of had this like quasi product that was very, very blue and tapey for our existing customers. But it was pretty cool. And then, you know, hell has to freeze over for me to take another VC dollar. And then in March of 2022, I think we all remember that. Got some preemptive term sheets, blah, blah, blah. Next thing you know, we're a funded company.
字面意思上看到了这些长相不太好的界面，然后说：“嘿，我们能点那个按钮吗？”我们说：“行啊，当然可以。”于是我们就开始做那个。然后突然之间，我们有了一个准产品，对于现有客户来说非常简陋（用胶带拼凑的）。但它挺酷的。然后，除非地狱结冰，否则我绝不会再拿风投的一分钱。然后在 2022 年 3 月，我想我们都记得那次。拿到了一些抢先的投资条款清单（term sheets），等等等等。紧接着，我们成了一家有资金支持的公司。
But that's turned into a great decision. And we've been able to build a really cool product that we're super proud of. So that's how we got to Shipyard, to answer awesome great story great story all right well that that's actually a good setup segue for i think what i i'd like to dig in on so people i guess you know i can't speak for everyone because i predate people learning to program by doing javascript as like even really an option or even before really doing Python. So for me, I resonate with, you know, Oh, a bare metal build system, right? I'm, I have GCC and I can compile my C program and, you know, I have my computer, but one of the things that I think
但这演变成了一个极好的决定。我们已经能够构建一个我们超级自豪的非常酷的产品。所以这就是我们如何走到 Shipyard 的，为了回答——太棒了，伟大的故事，伟大的故事。好吧，这实际上是一个很好的铺垫，为我想深入探讨的内容做准备。所以人们，我想，我不能代表所有人，因为我比通过把学 JavaScript 作为真正选项、甚至在真正学 Python 之前就开始学习编程的人要早。所以对我来说，我能感同身受，哦，裸机构建系统，对吧？我有 GCC，我可以编译我的 C 程序，而且，你知道，我有我的计算机。但我觉得其中一件事是，
even before, before scaling up a team that you run into is, Oh, Jason compiles and I compile, we have two different versions of gcc two different compilers and all of a sudden like our binaries don't behave the same way right we don't have i guess the term is like hermetic build system right like all of our things aren't self-contained in such a way that like maybe his libraries are different than my libraries right and with c maybe this is a little less of an issue. You don't tend to have tons and tons of dependencies. But okay, so I kind of started it bare metal.
甚至在扩大团队规模之前，你就会遇到：哦，Jason 编译了，我也编译了，我们有两个不同版本的 GCC，两个不同的编译器，突然之间我们的二进制文件表现得不一样了，对吧？我们没有，我想这个术语叫“可重复构建系统（hermetic build system）”对吧？就像我们所有的东西都不是自包含的，以至于也许他的库和我的库不一样，对吧？对于 C 语言来说，这可能稍微没那么是个问题。你往往不会有大量的依赖项。但好吧，所以我有点从裸机开始。
You have like your computer running your operating system and your compiler compiling your source code. Kind of take us from there, from like what your observation is. And it doesn't have to be on that. Maybe if it's for JavaScript, I think there's some analogies there as well. But like, how do people sort of move up the pyramid or move up the stack of saying like hey this is like
你的电脑运行着你的操作系统，你的编译器编译着你的源代码。请带我们从那里开始，讲讲你的观察。不一定非得是那个。也许如果是关于 JavaScript 的话，我想这其中也有一些类比。但是，人们是如何从那种，
a single user focused thing to the rest of the life cycle after that sure yeah that's a that's a it's a big question but i'll do my best we can take it in parts yeah no no well we're talking about my school days you're you're doing c plus plus and c so i'm feeling a little insecure so i want to like remember something from my compilers class to sound smart but i don't know if that's going to happen so okay so at the core you have a gate no only nand gates that's what i mean so let me just talk to you in adders all right so so yeah so i the one big, a big difference here is that between compiled language and a lot of the stuff that's happening in the world that we're in and, and sorry, so Shipyard,
单用户专注的东西，逐步攀登金字塔，或者说攀登技术栈，来到之后的整个生命周期的？当然，是的，这是一个很大的问题，但我会尽力而为。我们可以分部分来谈。不，不，好吧，我们在谈论我的学生时代，你当时在用 C++ 和 C，所以我感觉有点缺乏安全感，我想从我的编译课上记起一些东西来显得自己很聪明，但我不知道这会不会发生。好吧，所以在核心处，你有一个门——只有与非门（nand gates），这就是我所说的。所以让我只用加法器（adders）来跟你谈谈。好了。所以，是的。那么，这里的一个大区别在于，在编译型语言与我们所处世界中发生的许多事情之间，抱歉，所以 Shipyard，
the world that we're in is we are helping applications. So typically SaaS applications. So, okay, great. All right. These are, these are web based typically, sometimes mobile applications, database, application logic, maybe an inference engine. So this is not for compiled programs, really. Actually, Shipyard is not at all, but it's a good analogy. So it's more for interpreted stuff there with Python, JavaScript, that type of thing that you're talking about. But in general, I think the
我们所处的这个世界，我们是在帮助应用程序。所以通常是 SaaS 应用程序。所以，好的，太棒了。这些通常是基于网页的，有时是移动应用程序、数据库、应用逻辑、也许还有推理引擎。所以这其实不是针对编译型程序的。实际上，Shipyard 完全不是，但这是一个很好的类比。所以它更多是针对你刚才谈到的 Python、JavaScript 那类解释型语言的。但总的来说，我认为
connection between compiling to an application delivery is pretty straightforward. And what the common practice is today, I could talk about the old practice, but the common practice is to use something called containers, and typically something called Docker. I believe, I'm sure you guys are familiar with that. Yeah, these are words that I've heard before. These are words that you've heard before. So what a container is, is it's sorry, what a Docker, I'll just start with a Docker file. What a Docker file is, is it's literally a list of commands with some smart caching in there. So it's like, use Ubuntu 20, not npm install, what is apt get, whatever. So you literally write this out in your Docker file, so that you have those
从编译到应用程序交付之间的联系非常直接。今天通用的做法是——我可以谈谈旧的做法，但通用的做法是使用所谓的容器，通常是叫做 Docker 的东西。我相信，我确信你们对此很熟悉。是的，这些都是我以前听过的词。这些都是你以前听过的词。那么什么是容器呢，它是——抱歉，什么是 Docker，我从一个 Dockerfile 开始讲起。Dockerfile 实际上就是一系列带有某种智能缓存的命令。所以它就像是：使用 Ubuntu 20，不是 npm install，而是 apt get，诸如此类的。你实际上是在 Dockerfile 中写出这些，以便拥有这些
libraries, because dependency stuff is, I think think i think naming and dependency problems and cache and validation are the three unified things oh man there you go yeah it's like the three so so you basically get your dependencies you're in this file and there's some really smart caching stuff so that it can be faster to to bring your image which is is where your container lives okay i don't know if I'm doing a good job of explaining what a container is, but it's basically a way to encompass your operating system and all the necessary libraries
库，因为依赖项问题是——我想命名、依赖项问题和缓存失效是三大统一的问题。哦，天哪，确实如此。所以你基本上把你的依赖项写在这个文件里，并且有一些非常智能的缓存机制，这样可以加快获取镜像的速度，而镜像就是你的容器生存的地方。好吧，我不知道我有没有把容器解释清楚，但它基本上是一种将你的操作系统以及运行给定程序所需的
that that needs to run a given program. And so let's just take the example of Python. You might need certain pip packages for whatever reason. So I would have a Docker file that's a containment of that. And then I can mount in my code, my Python code, right into the so that's kind of the way that you encapsulate various things. Now, you might have that, you might have a Python application, you might have a node application, you might have a Rust application, you might have a Go app, we maybe even have a C++ application, they all can be contained in their own containers. That's probably a good way to do it. And then you need something to orchestrate turning those on and off. And so what that means is that you have things like Kubernetes, which are a scheduler or orchestrator. And those things can turn on and off the various
所有必要库打包在一起的方法。让我们以 Python 为例。出于某种原因，你可能需要特定的 pip 包。所以我会有包含这些内容的 Dockerfile。然后我可以把我的代码，我的 Python 代码，直接挂载进去，所以这就是你封装各种东西的方式。现在，你可能有这个，你可能有一个 Python 应用程序，你可能有一个 Node 应用程序，你可能有一个 Rust 应用程序，你可能有一个 Go 应用程序，我们甚至可能有一个 C++ 应用程序，它们都可以包含在它们自己的容器中。这可能是个好方法。然后你需要一些东西来编排这些容器的开启和关闭。这意味着你有像 Kubernetes 这样的工具，它们是调度器或编排器。这些东西可以开启和关闭我刚才向你描述的各种
containers that I just described to you to help orchestrate their ability to use each other. So just say I had a Python application, I have a container for that, but it needs a database. I have a second container that's my Postgres data container. And then the orchestration piece, okay, you guys can see my hands, they can't, but the orchestration piece says, hey, make sure that database is up before that application, Python thing is up because they can't talk to each other is that a decent high level overview yeah i mean i think that makes sense so for people who and we've covered some of the stuff with containers before on the show but just just as a reminder not forcing people to do the entire backlog so the difference between i think most people kind of know what a
容器，来帮助编排它们互相调用的能力。打个比方，假设我有一个 Python 应用程序，我为此有一个容器，但它需要一个数据库。我有第二个容器，那是我的 Postgres 数据容器。然后编排部分——好吧，你们能看到我的手势，他们看不到——但编排部分说：“嘿，确保数据库在那个 Python 应用程序启动之前就已经启动了，因为它们无法互相交谈。”这算是一个不错的宏观概述吗？是的，我的意思是这说得通。所以对于那些——我们以前在节目中介绍过一些关于容器的内容，但作为提醒，不用强迫大家去看整个节目档案——大多数人大概都知道什么是虚拟机，虚拟机是在你的电脑上运行你电脑上所有东西的一个版本：它自己的硬盘、它自己的内存、它自己的 CPU。我们不讨论仿真与否的一些细微差别，但基本上就是运行所有东西的一个实例并将其全部打包，然后你可以运行多个虚拟机，它们可以互相切换，你可以保存状态，所以不像你的正常电脑，它是完全由软件控制的。从虚拟机过渡到容器。你有什么优势——为什么这是人们从一种迁移到另一种的方式？当然，抱歉，这是一个很好的问题。使用虚拟机时，你拥有操作系统和应用程序代码的完整快照，对吧？使用容器，
virtual machine is and a virtual machine is running a version of all of the things on your computer on your computer so its own hard drive its own memory its own cpu we won't get into some of the nuances between emulation or not but but basically running an instance of everything and wrapping it all up and then you could run multiple vms and they can switch between each other you could save the state so unlike your normal computer it's completely software controlled. Going from a virtual machine to a container. What what kind of advantages are you unlike? Like, why is that been the migration for people to move from one to the other? Sure. Sorry, that's a great question. So with a virtual machine, you have a full snapshot of the operating system, and the application code, right? With containers,
而你实现这一点的方法是使用虚拟机监控程序（hypervisor）。所以它实际上是在硬件级别。因此，拥有一个用于安全性的硬件层有一些重大的安全优势，但它绝不完美。例如，心脏出血漏洞（Heartbleed）。所以没有什么是完美的。但在容器中，你在做的是——这可能是一个很好的解释，
and the way that you do that is using the hypervisor. So it's actually at the hardware level. So there is some major security benefits to having a hardware layer for security, but it's never perfect. Heartbleed, for example. So nothing's perfect. But with containers, what you're doing, and this is probably a really good thing to explain,
抱歉打断一下——你将操作系统作为一个共享资源。所以它实际上活在底层的虚拟机里，如果你使用——如果你打开 Docker Desktop，最底层其实有一个虚拟虚拟机，那就是共享资源。然后你的容器非常轻量，坐在顶部，只拥有操作系统顶部可能不存在的层。所以 Redis 可能需要一个密码学包，而 Python 需要一个身份验证包。我不知道，但它们在容器中都使用相同的底层 OS。为了说清楚，容器在安全性方面存在劣势，
sorry about that, is that you have the operating system as a shared resource. So it's actually living in a virtual machine at the bottom, like if you use if you turn on Docker desktop, there's actually a virtual virtual machine at the very bottom, that is the shared resource. And so then your containers are very lightweight, sit on top and just have the layers on top of that operating system that might not exist. So Redis might need a cryptography package and Python needs a authentication package. I don't know, but they're both using the same underlying OS in the container. So there's security disadvantages to containers to be clear,
但它有一个共享资源的东西。所以你从中得到的是轻量得多。所以如果我想停止我的虚拟机并把它发给你，根据具体内容，那可能是一个 4 GB 的文件，对吧？就像镜像一样。而对于容器来说，它实际上只是应用程序定义。所以我把它发给你。它只是一个小文件。然后你可能不得不拉取其他一些层，或者构建一些你可能没有的其他层，但你不是在构建 Ubuntu，你是在把它当作共享资源使用。所以它们要便携得多，而且你在底层拥有这些共享资源。所以效率高得多。因此，你可以——所以你不需要为我之前描述的每个服务单独划出一个完整的操作系统，底部几乎总有一个共享的操作系统。上面只有一些包，它们彼此隔离，但那里存在安全问题，所以——当然。那么——好吧，所以它是可组合的，我们可以组合一个 Python 包和一个 Redis，然后 Python 可以与 Redis 交谈，这样我们就可以为我们的网站提供服务，并拥有我们可以写入的数据存储。然后你谈到了 Kubernetes。
but there is a shared resource thing. So what you get out of that is much lighter weight. So like if I want to stop my VM and send it to you, like that could be, depending on what it is, a four gigabyte file, right? Like the image. Whereas with a container, it's literally just the application definition. So I send that over to you. It's just a little file. And then you might have to pull some other layers or build some other layers that you
所以 Kubernetes 不是用来编排将容器组合成一个整体的吗？我不知道这个术语是什么——当你有了一堆东西并想用 Kubernetes 编排它们时，这个术语叫什么？我不知道。我没有合适的术语来形容那个。
might not have, but you're not building Ubuntu and you're using it as a shared resource. So they're a lot, they're a lot more portable and you have these shared resources underneath. So it's a lot more efficient. So you can have, so instead of having to carve out an entire operating system for each one of those services I described before, there's a shared one at the bottom almost always. And then there's just the packages on top that are they are gated from each other but there's security issues there so sure so then so okay so it's composable and we can compose a python package and a redis and then the python can talk to the redis so we can serve serve our website and have our you know data store that we can we can write to so then then you talk
所以我的意思是，基本上，这是一个包含一堆 Pod 的 Kubernetes 集群。Pod 基本上就是容器。然后这些容器通常是——或者抱歉，Pod 通常位于所谓的命名空间（namespace）中。所以你的集群可以有 N 个命名空间。但也有一些——你把所有的 Pod 放到一个容器里，它们可以自动互相通信。如果你想跳出那个命名空间，那就是另一套
about kubernetes so k Kubernetes isn't for orchestrating the composing of the containers into one. I don't know what the term, what is the term for like, you have the collection of things and you want to orchestrate them with Kubernetes. I don't know. I don't have the right term for that.
权限控制了。Kubernetes 和 CNCF 生态系统很大一部分都是关于安全控制的。以及所谓的 RBAC 或基于角色的验证——我不知道 AC 代表什么。RBAC。我知道它是干什么的。我应该知道那个。基于角色的访问控制（Role Based Access Control）。谢谢。
So I mean, it's basically, it's a Kubernetes cluster that contains a bunch of pods. Pods are basically containers. And then those containers are typically, or sorry, pods are typically in what is known as a namespace. So your cluster can have n number of namespaces. But there's some like, you put all your pods in a container, they can talk to each other automatically. And if you want to break out of that namespace, that's a whole
那是个测试。你通过了测试。干得好。好的。所以，我们在编排这一切。而这看起来像——作为今天这个角色的开发者，我可能在非常晚的时候才会关心这个。当我的应用程序已经启动并运行之后，我可能已经走得很远了。纯粹就个人而言。因为这不是我以前做过的事情。
other permission thing. A large part of the Kubernetes and CNCF ecosystem is all about security controls. And what's known as RBAC or Role Based Authentic I don't know what the AC stands for. RBAC. I know what it does. I should know that. Role Based Access Control. Thank you.
所以我可以想象你正在解释你是如何走到这一步的历程。人们逐步构建他们的东西，这并不罕见。他们开始运行多个实例，也许带有一些负载均衡器。你看，我知道点东西。前面有一个负载均衡器在分发，然后意识到，哦，等等。这实际上是一个难以维持和运行的噩梦。然后你开始引入像 Docker 和 Kubernetes 这样的工具。但它们增加了一个
That was a test. You passed the test. Good job. Okay. So, all right. So we're orchestrating all of this. And this seems like I probably, as the developer in the role I am today, I probably care about this awfully late. I'm probably really far along in having my application up and working. Just personally. Because this isn't something that I've done before.
全新的安全和复杂性层。当我看到这些工具时，我其实并不一定理解它们是做什么的，因为它们正在解决一个我还不能感同身受的问题。我想这大概就是你所说的那些把自己搞得一团糟然后打电话叫你们去说“嘿，我们需要帮我们收拾烂摊子”的公司所处的状态。是的，没错。所以我认为现代的方法，大概在过去五到六年里，而且我要说，这完全要归功于 Docker 那个生态系统，那就是现在，如果你在编写任何规模的网络应用程序，你几乎总是尝试从一个容器开始。
So I imagine you kind of explaining the narrative of how you got to where you are. This isn't uncommon that people sort of build up their stuff. They start running multiple instances, maybe with some sort of load balancer. I'll see, I know something. Load balancer up in the front distributing, and then realizing, oh, hang on. This is actually a nightmare to sort of keep up and running. And then you sort of start bringing in tools like Docker and Kubernetes. But add a whole
这对所有企业来说并非都是如此，也有例外。特别是如果你在做真正的底层工作，我觉得这就没意义了。但作为开发者，你通常希望在本地尽可能接近生产环境。这一直是总括性的目标。在出现 Docker 之前，这不是一个触手可及的目标。而且它现在还是有点瑕疵。但是，是的，你可能只想在你的桌面上在本地安装这些包。然后，当需要共享应用程序、协作开发应用程序或托管应用程序时，问题就变成了：我该去哪里？所以我们今天开始看到的一种典型模式，我说过，过去三年里相当典型，那就是：你在本地开发某样东西，
new layer of security and sophistication. When I look at those tools, I don't really understand, you know, necessarily what they do, because they're solving a problem that isn't a problem I relate to yet. And I think that's likely where you were sort of getting at where companies get themselves into a bit of a mess, and then call you in and say, Hey, we need help with the mess. Yeah, that's right. So I think a modern approach, probably in the last five to six years, and this is, I would say, completely thanks to Docker and that ecosystem, is that these days, if you're writing a web application of any size, you almost always try and start off with a container.
试图在某种程度上将其容器化——如果你愿意的话，有很多开发者平台可以自己做到这一点，并在本地实现一点编排。但然后你如何把它弄进生产环境？以及中间的所有过渡环境，这就是 Shipyard 发挥作用的地方。好的，太棒了。所以“中间的环境”这个词，我想我们可能通过这集的标题暗示过这一点。但是，这里的这个词——环境，那是什么？你是什么意思？当然。当我在本地处理应用程序时，那是我的本地开发环境，对吧？这意味着我可以在本地让它工作，我开启 Postgres，我开启 Python，无论什么。
That's not true for all enterprise, and there are exceptions to this. And especially if you're doing like real low level stuff, like I don't think it would make sense. But you typically want to get as close to production locally as a developer as possible. That's always kind of the overarching goal. It was not an accessible goal up until kind of this Docker thing. And it's still a little flawed. But yeah, you might want to just install these packages locally on your desktop. And then when it's time to share the application or collaborate on the application or host the application, then it's just like, where do I go? So the typical pattern that we're starting to see today that I've said, I would say over the last three years is pretty typical, is you have a situation where you develop something locally,
然后，在大多数公司的典型软件开发生命周期中还有其他环境，特别是在应用程序方面。它们通常是高级开发环境。这是一个共享的地方，所有的代码都在这里供所有开发人员去查看，比如在网页上，在云端的某处。然后通常还有一些版本的测试环境、预发布环境以及生产环境。这只是一个宏观的版本。
you try and containerize it to some degree, as a, there's a lot of developer pluses out there, if you will, that kind of do it themselves and kind of get that little bit of orchestration going locally. But then how do you get that into production? And then all the intermediary environments in between, that's kind of where Shipyard comes in for all of this stuff. Okay, awesome. So this word environments in between, and I guess we might have cued that in
所以这个想法是，当你正在开发一个功能时，你从本地开始。一旦你对一个功能感觉良好——你从本地开始。一旦你感觉良好，你把它放到一个共享空间里，也许从其他开发人员那里得到一些反馈，也许做一个代码审查。一旦你对编写的代码满意，你就会把它合并到主分支中。一旦发生这种情况，它就会希望通过某种系统进入某种预发布环境，其他利益相关者通常会在那里查看它——按理说应该这样——并且你运行一些测试。一旦你对此满意，你就会通过某种系统把它发布到世界上。现在，我刚刚向你们描述的所有东西就是所谓的——我知道你们
by the name of the episode. But all right, what here, this word environment, what is that? What do you mean by that? Sure. So when I'm working on an application locally, that's my local development environment, right? It means that like, I can make it work locally, I have I turn on Postgres, I turn on Python, whatever,
根据剧集的名称。但是好吧，这里的这个词“环境”，那是什么？你这话是什么意思？当然。所以当我在本地开发一个应用程序时，那就是我的本地开发环境，对吧？这意味着，比如说，我可以让它在本地运行，我启动了Postgres，启动了Python，诸如此类，
then there are other environments in the typical software development lifecycle of most companies, especially on the application side. And they are typically high level development. So this is a shared place where all the code is living for all the developers to go look like in the web, in the cloud somewhere. Then there are typically some versions of testing environments and then staging environments and then production. And that's just like a high level version of this.
然后在大多数公司的典型软件开发生命周期中，还有其他环境，特别是在应用程序端。它们通常是高级开发环境。所以这是一个共享的地方，所有开发人员的代码都住在那里，可以去看看，比如在网络上，在云端的某个地方。然后通常还有一些版本的测试环境，然后是暂存环境，然后是生产环境。这只是一个宏观的版本。
And so the idea is, is that as you're working on a feature, you start locally. Once you feel on a feature, you, you start locally. Once you feel good about it, you put that in a shared space, maybe get some feedback from another developer, maybe do a code review. Once you're happy with, with the code that you've written, then you would merge it into the main branch. And then once that happens, then it gets hopefully into some type of staging where other stakeholders look at it typically, sort of, they're supposed to, and you run some tests. And then once you're happy with that, you release it out to the world through some system. Now, all of the thing I just described to you is what's known as, and I know you guys
所以这个想法是，当你正在开发一个功能时，你从本地开始。一旦你对一个功能感觉良好，你，你从本地开始。一旦你对此感觉良好，你把它放到一个共享空间中，也许可以从另一个开发人员那里得到一些反馈，也许做一个代码审查。一旦你对你编写的代码感到满意，那么你就会把它合并到主分支中。然后一旦发生这种情况，希望它能进入某种暂存环境，其他利益相关者通常会看一下，某种程度上，他们应该这样做，然后你运行一些测试。一旦你对此感到满意，你就会通过某个系统把它发布到世界上。现在，我刚刚向你描述的所有事情就是众所周知的，我知道你们
know this, is CI. So, you know, continuous integration. And there's a lot of tools for that that are basically the shepherds of all this stuff. Personally, we use CircleCI and GitHub Actions, but I've used Jenkins and Travis and Argo and Flux over the years. There's a lot of good options here. Buildkite's another great one that I like those guys a lot. So yeah, so that's kind of what these environments mean.
知道这个就是CI，也就是持续集成。有很多工具基本上充当了所有这些东西的“牧羊人”。就我个人而言，我们使用CircleCI和GitHub Actions，但这些年来我也用过Jenkins、Travis、Argo和Flux。这里有很多不错的选择。Buildkite是另一个很棒的工具，我很喜欢那里的团队。所以，这就是这些环境所代表的含义。
One thing that might be obvious here is how do you know when to merge and deploy a new environment is a big challenge for internal DevOps and also development teams. And then the other thing there is, should that be manual? Should that be automatic? And so there's a whole, and the whole point of continuous means that it's supposed to be automatic, but that is a very hard thing to achieve internally at software teams, typically. So I understand in the production environment you have users stimulating your application doing things hopefully hopefully have customers and they're they're using it for things in this sort of staging i guess this is
这里可能显而易见的一个问题是，如何知道何时合并以及部署新环境，这对内部DevOps以及开发团队来说是一个巨大的挑战。另一个问题是，这个过程应该是手动的，还是自动的？因此，这里存在一个完整的——“持续”的全部意义就在于它应该是自动的，但这在软件团队内部通常很难实现。所以我理解，在生产环境中，有用户在刺激你的应用程序，在做各种事情，希望你拥有客户，他们正在使用它来做各种事情；而在这种所谓的“中转”或“预发布”环境中，我想这是
where traditionally i would sort of you have either qa scripts or people going and simulating you know interaction with the application and then in sort of development is it it's the developers who are going in and sort of like pushing buttons and clicking things and getting databases set up is that is that roughly like how the each of the that's that's exactly right i mean and it's it's bespoke for every organization and that's part of the problem. It's like there is no one way to do this. There's a lot of different versions. I would almost go as far to say that literally every single software application
传统上我会说，你要么有QA脚本，要么有人去模拟你与应用程序的交互，然后在大致的开发阶段，是开发人员亲自去推动按钮、点击内容并设置数据库。是不是大致就是这样——每个环节都是这样的？完全正确，而且每个组织的情况都是量身定制的，这也是问题的一部分。就像没有哪一种方法是固定不变的。有很多不同的版本。我甚至可以说，几乎每一个软件应用程序
has its own unique version of every single thing we just described, except for those using Shipyard, then there is some commonality. But literally every single application has its own little nooks and crannies and little knobs that you need to tweak to actually make it work and that's all that's typically contained within the devops person's brain or who's ever responsible for that and they already have so much stuff to do that's kind of where the problems begin from an efficiency perspective and velocity perspective that makes sense so i have some feature up and it needs like some state in order to be
都有其独一无二的版本，涵盖我们刚刚描述的每一个细节，除了那些使用Shipyard的用户，那样的话会有一些共性。但实际上，每一个应用程序都有其独特的小角落、小缝隙以及你需要调整的小旋钮，才能真正让它运行起来，而这些通常都只装在DevOps人员或负责此项工作的人的脑子里。他们已经有太多事情要做了，从效率和交付速度的角度来看，这就是问题开始的地方。这说得通。所以我有了一个功能，它需要某种状态才能
able to to be tested i mean is this is this kind of like where we end up needing something a little bit more sophisticated is like hey i want something to be in a given place to demonstrate to someone else it works or to debug an issue. From what we've talked about so far, that seems like a lot of effort for me to go curate a specific something into the state ready for demonstrating my stuff or having it work. You know, I'm adding something
进行测试。我的意思是，这是否就是我们最终需要更复杂一点的东西的地方？比如，嘿，我想让某个东西处于特定位置，以便向其他人展示它能工作，或者用来调试问题。从我们目前讨论的内容来看，这似乎需要我付出很大的努力去精细化地准备某种状态，以便展示我的成果或让它正常运行。你知道，我正在往
to the end of the checkout process. So you need someone to go pick something off of a page, add it to the cart, enter their information. But, and then you can show me, that's a lot of work for someone else to do to approve a PR or whatever. Is this the kind of stuff where you begin to start to run into issues with sort of like how everyone sort of shares these things around? Or where do people start running into the downsides of just kind of one-off doing all
结账流程的末尾添加一些东西。所以你需要有人去页面上挑选一件商品，把它加入购物车，输入他们的信息。然后你才能展示给我看，这对于其他人来说要完成PR审批或其他什么任务，实在是需要做大量的工作。这就是你开始遇到诸如大家如何共享这些东西之类的问题的地方吗？或者人们在哪里开始遇到这种“一次性搞定所有这一切”的弊端？
of this? So, I mean, the place to start here is with the software development lifecycle in general, right? So typically, a product person works with a designer or UX person and says, Hey, I want feature x, I want this blue button to do this when you click it in the existing application. Eventually, the design for that gets over to a developer, and it's kind of thrown over a wall, the developer creates the feature. And then at some point, that product person gets to see that feature. So that's the first problem. The problem is, is that a developer could work on a feature. And two weeks later, they're getting feedback, hey, that's the wrong color blue, or when you click this, it's supposed to do that, not this. So then there's this huge developer
所以，我的意思是，要探讨这个问题，首先得从整体的软件开发生命周期说起。通常情况下，产品经理会与设计人员或UX人员合作，然后说：“嘿，我想要X功能，当在现有应用程序中点击这个蓝色按钮时，我希望它能这样运作。”最终，这个设计会转交给开发人员，有点像是“甩手掌柜”式的交接，由开发人员来创建该功能。接着在某个时候，产品经理有机会看到这个功能。所以这就是第一个问题。问题在于，开发人员可能在一个功能上忙活了
context switching cost. Because as a developer myself, and I'm sure you can speak to this, like when it's in my brain, my mental model is all filled out. No problem. The second it's out, like it's like, oh God,
两周后才收到反馈：“嘿，这个蓝色颜色不对，或者当你点击这个时，它应该做那个，而不是这个。”因此，这里就会产生巨大的开发人员上下文切换成本。因为作为一名开发人员，我确信你也能感同身受，当它还在我的脑海里时，我的心智模型是完全建立好的，一点问题也没有。但只要它一旦脱离脑海——就像是“天哪，
I don't even know why I named it. Like I don't even know what I was doing. Don't worry for any Shipyard customers. I am not programming anymore. So that's rest assured. This is not a problem for Shipyard. I have no longer, I haven't had to commit to the- You had it taken away from you, huh?
我甚至不记得我为什么要这么命名了，我甚至不知道我当时在干什么”。不用担心，各位Shipyard的客户，我再也不写代码了。所以请放心，这对Shipyard来说不是问题。我已经不再需要向——你被剥夺了这项权力，是吧？
I literally have not had to commit to the co-base in six months to protect our customer. But- That's not entirely true, but somewhat true. But that feedback loop being very long is really taxing. And it's a stop and start type situation for the developer. It's also super frustrating for product people. Now take that one step further. So you have a product person that says, Okay, this is the right color blue. But then there's a QA engineer
我实际上已经有六个月不需要向代码库提交代码了，这是为了保护我们的客户。但是——这虽然不完全真实，但也差不太多。不过，很长的反馈循环确实非常折腾。对于开发人员来说，这是一种“走走停停”的情况。对于产品人员来说，这也超级令人沮丧。现在把这个推进一步。所以你有一个产品经理说：“好吧，这个蓝色颜色对了。”但接下来又有一个QA工程师
or automated QA test or auto manual QA tester that another two days later is like, Oh, hey, like this broke this other thing that you didn't realize. And you're like, well, I just fixed this other thing. And I moved back to my other feature. So the whole point of shipyard and ephemeral environments in general, it's really a methodology where as soon as it's off of my fingertips, and I'm ready to commit this and share this with a developer or anybody like that, it should be asynchronously available for all these other key stakeholders to look at and give feedback so that everything just gets tighter. It's much tighter feedback loop. And then also product people aren't frustrated. QA people aren't doing the hurry up and wait, which is very typically their lives. And so it just all becomes kind of synchronous. Now,
或自动QA测试、或是手动QA测试人员，在两天后说：“哦，嘿，这破坏了你没意识到的另一个功能。”而你会想：“呃，我刚刚才修复了别的问题，而且我又转去开发其他功能了。”所以Shipyard以及临时环境（Ephemeral Environments）的核心意义，实际上是一种方法论：一旦它脱离了我的指尖，并且我准备好提交它并与开发人员或任何其他人分享时，它就应该能够异步地供所有其他关键利益相关者查看并给出反馈，从而让整个流程变得更加紧密。这是一个更紧密的反馈循环。同时产品人员也不会感到沮丧。QA人员也不用再经历“快点然后干等”的日常，而这通常就是他们的生活写照。因此一切都会变得非常同步。现在，
the other big pain point there is that if you wanted to do this without ephemeral environments, or at least good stage, well, without ephemeral environments or at least good stage, well, really ephemeral environments, you can, people do that, but that looks like, okay, product person, I've got a 45 minute screen share with you. We're now in a remote world anyway. So I've got a 45 minute screen share with you. You're going to give me feedback, but you're not even really able to click on it. Typically you can tell me what you want me to click on and then, okay,
另一个巨大的痛点是，如果你想在没有临时环境的情况下做到这一点，或者至少要有很好的阶段……好吧，如果没有临时环境或者没有好的阶段——其实如果没有临时环境，你也能做到，人们确实会这么做，但那看起来会是这样的：好吧，产品经理，我和你有45分钟的屏幕共享。无论如何，我们现在都处于一个远程办公的世界里。所以我和你有45分钟的屏幕共享。你要给我反馈，但你甚至无法亲自点击它。通常情况下，你只能告诉我你想让我点哪里，然后，好吧，
well maybe I'm more creative than that. So I'm going to use something like N grok, which is great. I love N grok, but even if I'm using N grok, which is a reverse proxy that can get you. So I can, if for those that don't know,
也许我比那更有创意一点。所以我会使用像ngrok这样的工具，它很棒。我很喜欢ngrok，但即使我使用的是ngrok，它也是一个能帮你实现内网穿透的反向代理。所以，对于那些不知道的人来说，我可以……
N grok is a great tool. You can turn it on locally and it kind of tunnels out to the world. Great here. Product person use this N grok link, but guess what, you're still running off of my local copy of it. Oh, actually, that's why I didn't know about that. Yeah. And then I can't do development because you need to test this thing. So I'm going to break what you're doing. So the solution here is giving everybody their own environment for every feature, multiple stakeholders for the same feature so your next point getting
ngrok是一个极好的工具。你可以在本地启动它，它会像打隧道一样连接到外部世界。很好，产品经理请使用这个ngrok链接。但你猜怎么着？你运行的仍然是我本地的那份拷贝。哦，其实，这就是我之前不知道这一点的原因。是的。然后我就无法继续开发了，因为你需要测试这个东西。所以我将打断你正在做的事情。因此这里的解决方案是：为每个功能给每个人提供他们自己的环境，针对同一个功能让多个利益相关者参与进来。所以你的下一个重点——
state right is the next huge challenge and the idea here is that you need a database with information in it or the application's not going to work to your exact point so replicating that data across all these these different environments and also it being sane like you can't just use stuff from six months ago you got to keep it up to date sync it across and then also giving well so now shipyard comes in and this is a feature that we're very proud of and people love there's like a data dashboard where you can actually cherry pick hey i want the state when i was working on this feature from two weeks ago i want to use that for this new pr that i'm doing
搞定状态（State），是接下来的又一个巨大挑战。这里的核心思想是：你需要一个包含数据的数据库，否则应用程序将无法按你的预期工作。因此，跨所有这些不同的环境复制这些数据，并确保数据是合理的——你不能直接使用六个月前的数据，你必须保持数据更新、同步，然后还要提供……好勒，现在Shipyard登场了，这是我们非常骄傲且深受用户喜爱的一项功能：有一个数据仪表盘，你可以在其中精挑细选——嘿，我想要我两周前开发这个功能时的状态，我想把它用于我正在做的这个新PR，
and vice versa so again without seeing my hands moving around i think the sound is smart but it's really cool so so you kind of like allow people to define oh just make up another term whatever you like allow people to find up like a bundle of data and say give it a name and be able to use that in multiple places. Yeah, that's basically correct. Huh. And then the, so more than, okay, I kind of see now. So the Docker file and everything is a piece of the puzzle. We have to describe how the thing builds, but it's only one piece.
反之亦然。再次说明，虽然看不到我的手势，但我认为听起来很聪明，而且它真的很酷。所以你基本上是允许人们定义——随便起个别的什么你喜欢的名字——允许人们定义一捆数据，给它起个名字，并能够在多个地方使用它。是的，基本上就是这样。哈。然后，我大概明白了。所以Docker文件和所有这些东西只是拼图的一部分。我们必须描述东西是如何构建的，但这只是其中一部分。
There's all these other bits and pieces that need to get brought in. And even teaching Docker itself how to go to, and I don't even know how that works i mean i guess i should imagine it was like hey i have a pr i'm working on but it needs to know hey i need to go pull that specific version of the code not just the code checked in or the tag or the latest it's like it needs to go to a very specific variant of maybe multiple code bases and pull them all in pull some data down get it all up and running so that many different people could come and like try something out. Yeah, that's that's exactly right. And yeah,
还有所有这些其他零零碎碎的东西需要被引入。甚至还要教Docker本身去……我甚至不知道它是怎么运作的，我想象的应该是：嘿，我有一个正在处理的PR，但它需要知道：嘿，我需要去拉取那个特定版本的代码，而不仅仅是签入的代码、标签或最新版本。它就像是需要去寻找可能多个代码库的某个非常特定的变体，把它们全部拉取下来，下载一些数据，然后把一切都启动并运行起来，以便许多不同的人可以过来尝试某些东西。是的，完全正确。而且，
we do have support for multi repo, which is another feature that we love not to plug shipyard too much. But yeah, there is two big things here to talk about just for your users is there's there's mono repo, which have all your code for everything in one big repo. Or what we're seeing a lot these days is multirepo. And people call that, I think they call that polyrepo. Also, it's another term people use where you might have your front end code with React in one repository, your backend code in Node in a different repository, and then another service in Rust or whatever. Coordinating all those to be on the right SHAs and the right hashes and getting
我们确实支持多仓库（multi-repo），这也是我们非常喜欢的一个功能——虽然这有点像在为主打产品Shipyard做宣传。不过，对于你的用户来说，这里有两件大事需要谈谈：一是单体仓库（monorepo），它把所有东西的代码都放在一个大仓库里。或者我们现在经常看到的——多仓库。人们把这叫做，我想他们也叫它“多仓库架构（polyrepo）”。这也是人们使用的一个术语，你可能会把用React编写的前端代码放在一个仓库里，把用Node编写的后端代码放在另一个仓库里，然后把另一个服务放在Rust或其他什么语言的仓库里。协调所有这些仓库以使用正确的SHA和正确的哈希值，并获取
the right, all those things is very challenging. It's doable. So let me be clear, like this is a, this is something that people have been doing within Google for, I don't know, 15 years, more than that. And large engineering orgs, but they have dedicated, you know, 100, 200 person DevOps teams that focus on that. So really, what what's happened here is that because of technologies, we're on the backs of giants on because of technologies like Docker, because of stuff like Kubernetes, which is all under the hood for everything shipyard does, to be clear, now this elastic compute that you get by being really fast to turn on and off, and it being smart, you can now do these types of environments very quickly and turn
正确的东西，所有这些都非常具有挑战性。但这并非不可行。所以我要说明白，这是一个人们在谷歌内部已经做了——我不知道，15年，甚至更久的事情。大型工程组织也是如此，但他们有专门的、100到200人的DevOps团队专门来做这件事。所以实际上，这里发生的事情是，由于技术的进步，我们站在了巨人的肩膀上——由于诸如Docker之类的技术，由于诸如Kubernetes之类的技术（顺便说一句，这些技术都是Shipyard所做一切的底层支撑），你可以通过快速开启和关闭来实现这种弹性计算，并且由于它是智能的，你现在可以非常快速地创建这些类型的环境，并开启或关闭它们，
them on turn them off because that's the other part we didn't even talk about cost controls like you don't want to have these environments running when no one's using them because it's expensive and wasteful so yeah so what shipyard is doing is kind of helping give devops people um they can focus on being an sre for production, not for internal tooling, because this is becoming, this is pretty much expected tooling for any decent size software SaaS company. Like say you're over 15 engineers, like you need to have multiple environments. Honestly, once you're over four or five engineers and you can't just like do a quick screen share, that's when you start running into like really bad releases. Yeah. And one other thing, maybe not the best time to bring it up,
因为这是我们甚至还没有谈到的另一个部分——成本控制。你绝对不希望在没有人使用这些环境时让它们一直运行，因为那既昂贵又浪费。所以，Shipyard正在做的事情是，帮助DevOps人员让他们能够专注于成为生产环境的SRE（站点可靠性工程师），而不是内部工具的SRE。因为这已经成为任何有一定规模的SaaS软件公司的标配工具。比如，如果你有超过15名工程师，你需要拥有多个环境。老实说，一旦你的团队超过四五名工程师，而你不能再通过简单的屏幕共享来解决问题时，你就会开始遇到非常糟糕的版本发布。是的。还有一件事，也许现在提出来不是最佳时机，
but I'll tell you anyways, is there's this concept of testing within our SaaS world. I'm sure you guys are more than aware. And there's unit testing. And then there's also what's known as functional testing, or more specifically end-to-end testing. Or I'm sorry, integration testing is what I meant to say. But end-to-end testing,
但我还是要告诉你，在我们SaaS世界里有一个关于测试的概念。我相信你们对此再清楚不过了。有单元测试，然后还有所谓的“功能测试”，或者更具体地说，是端到端（End-to-End）测试。或者抱歉，我本想说的是集成测试。但端到端测试，
where it's literally there's frameworks like Cypress or Playwright or selenium where they like have a fake browser that just clicks on buttons for you and you can script it so it literally brings up a browser and it's like a human and that's what i think jason you were talking about that earlier like the scripted qa stuff so you have the scripted qa stuff so if you have ephemeral environments you can run those tests before a huge... I make my PR, Shipyard create... This is what we're seeing and this is what we're doing ourselves and a bunch of customers
字面意思就是有一些框架，比如Cypress、Playwright或Selenium，它们就像有一个模拟浏览器，可以为你点击按钮，你可以通过脚本控制它，让它字面意义上调出一个浏览器，表现得就像真人一样。我想这就是你之前提到的Jason——那些脚本化的QA内容。所以你拥有脚本化的QA内容。如果你有了临时环境，你就可以在发生重大变更之前运行这些测试……我提交一个PR，Shipyard就会创建……这就是我们所看到的，也是我们自己以及许多客户正在做的事情。
are doing. There's case studies you can find on our website. But you bring up a PR, that PR automatically has end-to-end tests run against it. So before I even bring in my product person, or my code, my other developer for code review, or my QA person for manual QA, I already have a clean bill of health saying like, I'm not wasting any humans time, because I already know that all the things I expect to work still work. And if they don't, great, the developer gets feedback right away, they either update the test, or they update and they fix that. And the only way to do real end-to-end testing is with production-like environments,
你可以在我们的网站上找到相关的案例研究。但是当你提交一个PR时，该PR会自动对其运行端到端测试。因此，甚至在我引入产品经理、负责代码审查的其他开发人员或负责手动QA的QA人员之前，我已经获得了一份干净的“健康证明”，这告诉我：我没有浪费任何人类的时间，因为我已经知道所有我期望正常工作的预期功能仍然在工作。如果它们没有正常工作，太棒了，开发人员会立即获得反馈，他们要么更新测试，要么进行更新和修复。而进行真正的端到端测试的唯一方法，就是使用类生产（production-like）环境，
so full-stack environments. And that is a difficult thing to do. So you have to build that in your CI platform or use ShipGrid. So there's a lot of moving pieces. I'm beginning to see the picture of where the intricacies lay and why you might think at first like oh just one more little script or one more little thing but then like you're pointing out I mean we've had this before someone's like oh hey I have a Jenkins machine and there's like all these builds didn't get cleaned up because something hung or whatever and so they're just left suspended eating up eating up space let me just go write one more script to like anything exceeding you know 14 days and then someone has a job that they expect to take yeah it's just yeah it's a never-ending ending battle it's like it's like you like like the
也就是全栈环境。这是一件很困难的事情。所以你必须在你的CI平台中构建它，或者使用Shipyard。所以这里有许多动态的部分。我开始看清那些复杂细节所在的图景，以及为什么你一开始可能会觉得“哦，只需再加一个脚本或一小段东西就行了”，但就像你所指出的——我的意思是，我们以前也遇到过这种情况，有人说：“哦，嘿，我有一台Jenkins机器，由于某些程序挂起或其他原因，所有这些构建都没有被清理掉”，结果它们就被悬挂在那里，不断蚕食着空间。让我再去写一个脚本，把任何超过（比如说）14天的东西清理掉。然后有人又有一个他们期望能运行的任务……是的，这真是一场没完没了的战斗。这就好比
the carnival thing where the gophers pop out of the holes that's oh hack them all that is that is a very good description of a devops person's life and i am a devops person so i can say that so okay actually this this may be a good a bit late to have that conversation but i think it's a bit interesting as well this is a term that i've seen pop up a lot more recently than maybe when i first got started but this this like role of saying devops or i think we alluded to before SRE, like a site reliability engineer. Is that SRE? Okay, good.
嘉年华游乐园里那种地鼠从洞里钻出来的游戏，你得把它们全砸下去。那真是对DevOps人员生活的极好描述，而且我本人就是一个DevOps人员，所以我完全可以说这话。好吧，实际上，现在来谈这个话题可能稍微有点晚了，但我觉得这也挺有趣的。这是一个我最近比刚入行时更频繁听到的术语，那就是“DevOps”这个角色，或者像我们之前提到的SRE，即站点可靠性工程师。那是SRE吗？好的，明白了。
I got it. Something like that. Like these are terms that for like when I was starting, they weren't an option. They weren't, you know, what people would do. We knew of like sysadmins,
类似这样的角色。这些术语在我刚入行时并不是一种选择，不是人们会去做的事情。我们知道的是“系统管理员（sysadmin）”，
people who would like, you know, come to your computer and help you get your stuff and make sure everybody's developers had all the software they need. And you know, that, that kind of stuff. But what in your mind, like what is a DevOps engineer and what does that role really like mean and what does it entail? Yeah. I mean, so it's changing right now as we speak, I would say that the sysadmin that you're speaking of was, you know,
也就是那些会来到你的电脑前，帮你配置好各种东西，确保所有开发人员都拥有所需软件的人，以及诸如此类的事情。但在你看来，什么是DevOps工程师？这个角色真正意味着什么？它包含哪些工作？是的。我的意思是，它现在正在我们说话的同时发生变化。我会说，你刚才提到的那个系统管理员，
back in the day they were responsible for that sun box with the 128 processors that you only had two turned on for or whatever to make sure that pets.com would stay up and quickly people kind of realized okay sysadmins like they're good at what they do but like understanding real time systems and like what's like ch mod is not the only thing that you need to do so there's other skill sets that they're developing, but really this is a different, like you don't want someone that understands all of these like intricacies of keeping a production system up also dealing with like, Hey, I forgot to reset my password type thing.
过去他们负责的是那台拥有128个处理器、却只开启了其中2个的Sun微系统服务器，或者做类似的事情，以确保pets.com网站能够正常运行。很快人们意识到，好吧，系统管理员很擅长他们所做的事情，但仅仅理解实时系统，并且像执行`chmod`并不是你唯一需要做的事情——所以他们正在培养其他技能。但实际上，这是一种不同的角色。你不会希望一个既要理解保持生产系统平稳运行的所有复杂细节、又得处理诸如“嘿，我忘记重置密码了”之类杂事的人来兼顾这一切。
So a role was kind of created the DevOps role. I mean, I don't know the numbers on this, but I would guess like 10 or 15 years ago is when it probably came to some level of prominence. And that is like assist sysadmin slash developer because you also need to have a bit of understanding of application code because you need to be able to be like well this is failing here i'm looking at the log i have to jump into the code base and see if there's something obvious here and so it's kind of just like a developer
因此，一种名为DevOps的角色应运而生。我的意思是，我没有这方面的具体数据，但我猜大概在10到15年前，它可能开始达到某种程度的显赫地位。那是一种系统管理员兼开发人员的混合体，因为你还需要对应用程序代码有一定的理解，以便能够判断：“嗯，这里出故障了，我在看日志，我必须深入代码库看看这里是不是有什么显而易见的问题。”所以它有点像是一个开发人员加运维加系统管理员的角色，这就是DevOps人员。
operations sysadmin type role that's what a a DevOps person is. And so they're kind of responsible for everything. Or ideally, they're responsible for all your infrastructure to make sure that all works, which does include, hey, I'm a new developer joining company X, I want to make like, how do I start developing that day, that kind of became a little too encompassing. Because if I'm worrying about new developers turning off, like being able to develop, then I'm not worrying about production being efficient or going down or not going down. And basic, I don't know when this happened, but Google released the SRE handbook. I want to say eight years ago, maybe it was more than that. And they coined the term SRE,
因此他们基本上要对所有事情负责。或者理想情况下，他们要对你所有的基础设施负责，以确保所有这些都能正常工作，这确实包括——嘿我是加入X公司的新开发人员，我想知道我如何能从第一天就开始进行开发？——这种需求变得有点过于包罗万象了。因为如果我一直在操心新开发人员如何能够顺利开始开发，那么我就无法专注于生产环境的高效、不宕机或不出故障。而且基本上，我不知道这是什么时候发生的，谷歌发布了《SRE手册》。我想大约是八年前，也许更久。他们创造了SRE这个词，
that's site reliability engineer. And those folks are responsible for making sure that the site itself, if you will, so production, is reliable. The way they do that is with SLOs and SLAs and SLIs, which are little measurements of saying, I have a service level objective of having the database not be down more than five nines or whatever. And so my job is to keep it that way. The SRE is a DevOps person that's focused on production is kind of how I think of it, but that never holds true because SRE then ends up being like, well, I know how to fix
也就是站点可靠性工程师。这些人负责确保网站本身（如果你愿意这么叫的话）也就是生产环境是可靠的。他们实现这一目标的方式是通过SLO（服务目标）、SLA（服务等级协议）和SLI（服务质量指标），这些都是一些衡量标准，比如：我有一个服务等级目标，即确保数据库停机时间不超过五个9之类。所以我的工作就是让它保持这种状态。我眼中的SRE，本质上就是专注于生产环境的DevOps人员。但这从来都站不住脚，因为SRE最终往往会变成：“好吧，我知道如何修复
production. So I probably know how to fix your local development environment. And I might know how to fix, I definitely know how to fix staging, but it's going to take me a second. And like, remember, what these people are doing, it's always, it's never a quick thing, right? It's never like, oh, I have to change this one line of code and everything's fine. I have to change this one line of code and then all this stuff has to trigger, rebuild. Oh, you know what? This data is corrupted i'm gonna have to move over a 400 gigabyte postgres volume mount over there
生产环境，所以我大概也知道如何修复你的本地开发环境。我可能也知道如何修复预发布环境，但需要花我一点时间。”而且请记住，这些人正在做的事情从来都不是一件快的事，对吧？从来都不是说：“哦，我只要改这一行代码，一切就都好了。”我必须改这一行代码，然后所有这些东西都必须触发重新构建。哦，你知道吗？这些数据损坏了，我得把一个400GB的Postgres卷挂载过去。
that doesn't take two minutes that takes a while and depending on your iops i guess but it could take a while and guess what as a devops person or sre like i gotta make sure that doesn't get corrupted in the rsync so the point is is that that the DevOps life is a one of patience and a lot of focus and SRE life. So what I think is happening, what I see happening is you have SREs becoming real, just SREs, SREs, just focused on production, which is definitely the model that Google kind of prescribed to us. And it's a really good, you should check out the SRE handbook. I don't think you can Google that one pretty easily, obviously. And then the DevOps person is kind of like, how do I turn on Postgres correctly without causing a problem?
这可不只需要两分钟，这需要花上一段时间。根据你的IOPS（每秒输入输出操作数）可能会花更长时间。而且你猜怎么着？作为一名DevOps人员或SRE，我得确保数据在rsync同步过程中不会损坏。关键在于，DevOps的生活充满了耐心和高度的专注，SRE的生活也是如此。所以我想发生的事情、我所看到正在发生的事情是：你会看到SRE真正成为了纯粹的SRE——SRE们只专注于生产环境，这绝对是谷歌为我们开出的药方，而且这是一个非常好的模式，你应该去读读《SRE手册》。我想你可以很容易地在谷歌上搜到它，显而易见。然后DevOps人员的角色更像是：我如何正确启动Postgres而不会引发问题？
How do I orchestrate the application so that it works well? And ultimately, there is a huge lack of DevOps people in this world right now. And there's a huge need for them. And so that's kind of where Shipyard came from. Yeah. So Shipyard's role, help me here, is like to empower DevOps people or replace DevOps people? Well, I think empower DevOps people to be SREs for production. Like that's kind of the way that I look at it. The truth though, is that what we've built is what I have wanted to build every single time I've ever joined a company.
我如何编排应用程序以便它能良好运行？归根结底，这个世界上目前严重缺乏DevOps人员，对他们的需求非常巨大。所以这就是Shipyard诞生的背景。是的。那么Shipyard的角色——帮我理清一下——是赋能DevOps人员，还是取代DevOps人员？嗯，我认为是赋能DevOps人员，让他们成为生产环境的SRE。这大概就是我看待它的方式。不过事实是，我们所构建的东西，正是我在加入每一家公司时都一直想要构建的东西。
So there can be a little friction. I'm not going to lie. I get it. I have empathy for that. But ultimately what we've seen is that everyone, all the DevOps people we work with, once we've convinced them that our stuff works the way we say it's going to work and that the application definition is as simple as we say it's going to be right now, that's Docker composed. Just we can talk about that later. But once we
所以这其中可能会有一些摩擦。我不会撒谎，我懂，我对他们感同身受。但归根结底，我们所看到的是，每个人——所有与我们合作的DevOps人员，一旦我们说服他们相信我们的产品能够按照我们承诺的那样工作，并且应用程序的定义正如我们现在所说的那样简单——那就是Docker Compose（我们稍后可以讨论这个）。一旦我们
build trust, they love us, but they're definitely skeptical at the beginning. And it is a tool that everyone kind of wants to build. Like that is like the whole point is like, Hey, I make a change and automatically everything goes up and it's awesome and anyone can use it and then when they're done using it automatically goes down so it really is kind of you know it is the cool like it's what we all want to build so there's a little friction there but i but ultimately it works out. I'm going to jump in here and interrupt our interview today to talk about our sponsor, Zencastr. Zencastr is an all-in-one podcast production suite
建立了信任，他们就会非常爱我们，尽管他们在开始时肯定是持怀疑态度的。而且这是一个每个人都想自己去构建的工具。整个核心意义就在于：嘿，我做了一个更改，然后一切自动上线，这太棒了，任何人都可以使用它；当他们使用完后，它又会自动下线。所以它确实很酷，这就是我们所有人梦寐以求的构建成果。因此这里面会有一些摩擦，但归根结底一切都会顺利解决。我要插话打断一下我们今天的采访，来介绍一下我们的赞助商Zencastr。Zencastr是一个全方位的播客制作套件，
that gives you studio-quality audio and video without needing all that technical know-how. It records each guest locally, then uploads the crystal-clear audio and video right into the suite so you have high quality raw materials to work with. Jason and I have been using Zencastr for programming Throwdown for a while now and it's a huge upgrade over the way we used to do things. It's so much easier and more seamless to have everybody join a Zencastr room and get individual audio streams for each participant, which allows editing and
它能为你提供录音室级别的音频和视频，而无需你具备所有那些复杂的专业技术知识。它在本地录制每个嘉宾的音视频，然后将极其清晰的音频和视频直接上传到套件中，这样你就能获得高质量的原始素材来进行后期制作。Jason和我使用Zencastr来录制Programming Throwdown节目已经有一段时间了，与我们过去的方式相比，这是一个巨大的升级。让每个人加入同一个Zencastr房间，并为每个参与者获取独立的音频流，这要简单得多，也无缝得多，从而使剪辑和
mastering to go much more quickly. It just also feels like a better experience for all involved. I'm so happy that we have this new solution instead of the way we used to do things back when we first started. If you would like to try Zencastreroom to make your own podcast, you can get a free trial by going to zen.ai slash programming throwdown that's zen.ai slash programming throwdown back to the podcast and then so and then we can leave this topic but so devops people how do people kind of get into that i mean you were saying that you kind of self-titled your your that's your current roles like more like devops do people kind of get into that? I mean, you were saying that you kind of self-titled your, that's your current role, like more like DevOps-focused, this kind of thing.
母带制作能够更快完成。对于所有参与其中的人来说，这也感觉是一次更好的体验。我很高兴我们有了这个新解决方案，而不是回到我们刚起步时那种老旧的做法。如果你想尝试使用Zencastr制作你自己的播客，你可以通过访问 zen.ai/programmingthrowdown 来获取免费试用，网址是 zen.ai/programmingthrowdown。我们言归正传。那么，既然可以暂时离开这个话题——对于DevOps人员，人们是如何进入这个领域的？我的意思是，你刚才提到你自称你目前的工作就是偏向DevOps的。人们是如何涉足这个领域的？
Like you talked about being a background, you know, computer science, he's your family, this stuff, now you do DevOps. Is that a typical path you see people take? Do people come the other way? They start more like operating system, sysadmin, and then they add in some developers, a mix of both. Like you said, it's an under, I think I've heard that before like it's a under service role currently like it's a lot it's really hard to find these people that have the right mix of knowledge what is your take there if someone says that
我的意思是，你谈到了你的背景是计算机科学，你的家人也是干这个的，然后你现在做DevOps。这是一个你所看到的典型职业路径吗？人们会反过来走这条路吗？他们先是从操作系统、系统管理员做起，然后加入一些开发技能，还是两者的混合？就像你说的，这是一个服务不足的角色——我想我之前也听过这种说法，目前它是一个服务不足的角色，很难找到同时具备正确知识组合的人。你对此有什么看法？如果有人觉得这听起来非常有趣，那么正确的做法是什么——去谷歌搜索什么、关注什么、思考什么、去学校学什么？是的，我对此非常纠结，因为追根溯源，我觉得成为一名系统管理员是关键所在，但如果没有开发人员的知识，它就不会那么强大。所以我一直想说的是：去找一个代码库——我会把Shipyard的贡献给你。如果你去 github.com/slash-shipyard，我们会看到一堆入门级应用程序，比如Flask、Postgres等等。那里还有很多其他的选择。
sounds really interesting what's the what's the right thing to go sort of google look at think about go to school for yeah i'm very torn on this one because underneath it all i feel like being a sysadmin is the key but also without that developer knowledge it's not as powerful so i think that what i would always say is just find a repository i'll ship you if you go to github.com slash shipyard we have got a bunch of starter applications that are like flask, Postgres, whatever. But there's plenty of other options out there. And just get it working. If you really want to be serious about your career in DevOps land, I think having a basis of understanding Linux is probably the more challenging thing to pick up.
先把它跑通。如果你真的想认真对待你在DevOps领域的职业生涯，我认为掌握Linux的基础知识可能是其中更具挑战性的事情。所以你可能想把重点放在那上面。但同样，这 realmente 是关于好奇心。这就好比——如果你擅长处理问题，并且你渴望解决问题，DevOps是一个极好的切入领域，因为你会遇到最古怪的操作系统级别的问题，比如耗尽页面、内核、指针，你甚至不知道自己遇到的是什么问题。我认为要成为一名优秀的DevOps工程师，你必须是一个像样的开发人员和一个优秀的系统管理员，或者说系统管理人员，这就是我的看法。
So you probably want to maybe start your focus there. But also, it's really about curiosity. It's like, it's like, if you're good at dealing with problems, and you want to deal with problems, DevOps is a great role to be in because you just run into the weirdest operating system level problems, you run out of pages, kernel, pointer, you don't even know what stuff your problem you're having i think to be a good devops engineer you have to be a decent developer and a good system admin guy that's or admin person is what i would say that's a great observation i was trying to tell to people this like it's kind of interesting even the amount of operating system knowledge you're supposed to learn as a developer is sort of i don't, not counterintuitive,
这是一个绝佳的观察。我一直试图向人们指出这一点，这挺有意思的——甚至作为一名开发人员，你本应该学习的操作系统知识量，也不能说是反直觉的，
but not obvious in the start. Like, Oh, everyone should learn programming. You sit down and write a Python and okay. Do you know about apt get? Can you apt get install pip? Like what now I'm on windows. Where do I go? And it's like, Oh wait, hang on. You know? And we've gotten better at some of that stuff, I think collectively. But I think it's interesting that even now I would consider like I use Unix environments or Linux environments routinely, but I would not by any means dare to breathe the word like proficient or expert as like my ability, despite having been, you decades in the as a programmer that's that's because you have experience so people who put expert or are the people who just haven't learned how how little of an expert we actually are at everything yeah i cannot agree with that more
但在一开始并不是那么显而易见。就像，“哦，每个人都应该学编程。”你坐下来写Python，然后，这就行了。你知道`apt-get`吗？你会用`apt-get install pip`吗？现在我在Windows上，我该去哪？然后就像：“哦等等，稍等一下。”你知道吗？而且我认为我们大家在某些方面已经做得越来越好了。但我认为有趣的是，即使到现在，我也会认为——我经常使用Unix环境或Linux环境，但绝不敢大言不惭地用“精通”或“专家”来形容我的能力，尽管我作为程序员已经有几十年的经验了。那是因为你有经验，所以那些自称专家的人，其实正是那些还没学会我们实际上对所有事情都知之甚少的人。是的，对此我不能同意更多了。
the longer i get into my career the more i realize I don't know. So, yeah, I think that's a good observation. Well, cool. I mean, I think we're going to sort of like call that a pretty good coverage of the topic at hand. So let's talk about Shipyard as a company. Can you tell us a little bit about like Shipyard as a company? I know you talked about some recent changes and some things like are you guys growing? Are you hiring internship? What's it like to work there? Are you remote? Are you in office? And that was a big topic, but just sort
我在职业生涯中走得越远，就越意识到自己其实一无所知。所以，是的，我认为这是一个很好的观察。好吧，很酷。我的意思是，我认为我们可以把这看作是对当前话题的一个相当不错的全面探讨。那么让我们来谈谈Shipyard这家公司。你能给我们介绍一下Shipyard这家公司吗？我知道你谈到了最近的一些变化和事情——你们在发展吗？你们在招聘实习生吗？在那里工作是怎样的？你们是远程办公还是在办公室？这是一个宏大的话题，不过就
of give us the give us the pitch. Yeah, so okay, so the pitch is shipyard get an ephemeral environment on every pull request or coaching. So that's, that's the thing. But yeah, so we're a funded company, VC backed company, we've actually got some great investors. We're about 10 people. We are growing. We are hiring. Please check out our careers page for that. We are actively hiring. We are on Twitter at Shipyard Build. We also have a community site.
给我们做一个简短的介绍吧。好的，那么介绍是这样的：Shipyard，在每一个PR或代码提交上提供临时环境。这就是我们的核心。不过话说回来，我们是一家有融资的公司，一家由风险投资（VC）支持的公司，我们实际上有一些非常棒的投资人。我们团队大约有10人。我们在不断发展，我们在招人。请查看我们的招聘页面了解详情。我们正在积极招聘。我们在Twitter上的账号是 @ShipyardBuild。我们还有一个社区网站。
Actually, this is a good one called EphemeralEnvironments.io. I hope you put that in. Ephemeral is... I learned how to spell it, but it took me like 10 years. It'll be in the show notes. People will just be able to click on it. Great. And that's... So what that is, is that is a community site. PR is welcome. I learned how to spell it, but it took me like 10 years. It'll be in the show notes. People will just be able to click on it. Great.
实际上，这是一个很好的网站，叫做 EphemeralEnvironments.io。我希望你能把它放进去。Ephemeral 这个词……我学会怎么拼写它花了大约10年时间。它会出现在节目文稿中，大家可以直接点击。太棒了。这就是——这个网站是一个社区网站，欢迎提交PR。我学会怎么拼写它花了大约10年时间。它会出现在节目文稿中，大家可以直接点击。太棒了。
And that's, so what that is, is that is a community site. PR is welcome. And the whole idea here is that, as I mentioned, like ephemeral environments is not a new paradigm. It's just becoming an accessible one. And we're a part of that, but there are other people and other companies trying to work on this and just other open source projects out there. So these are kind of best practices of how to become ephemeral, how to use it, what to do. So you should check ephemeralenvironments.io. Our website is shipyard.build. Yeah. And so we're doing well. I had some really early success with some awesome design partners that we're really
这就是——那个网站是一个社区网站，欢迎提交PR。整个理念是，正如我所提到的，临时环境并不是一个新范式，它只是正在变得越来越容易获取。我们是其中的一部分，但还有其他人和公司在致力于此，也有其他开源项目存在。因此，这些是关于如何实现临时化、如何使用它以及该做什么的最佳实践。所以你应该去看看 EphemeralEnvironments.io。我们的网站是 shipyard.build。是的，我们现在发展得很好。我们从一些非常棒的设计合作伙伴那里获得了非常早期的成功，对此我们非常感激。是的，我们现在有一个免费试用版，实际上很快可能会推出免费层（free tier），但我不会官方宣布，不过我们正在为此努力。记住，我们的每一个环境——抱歉，我们拥有的每一个组织，或者我可能没告诉你这一点——都会获得它自己的集群。我们非常非常专注于安全，我们必须确保满足一系列合规要求，
thankful for. And yeah, and we have a free trial now, actually, soon to probably be a free tier but i'm not going to say officially but we're working on that remember every one of the environments i'm sorry every one of the organizations we have or maybe i didn't tell you this gets its own cluster we're very very security focused we have a bunch of regulations that we have to make sure we're on top of sock to um hipa all these other itar. So we're really good about we would try to be really good about security, but you can never be perfect, obviously. Yeah. Any other questions about shipyard that cover everything? No, I mean, I think what, what would you say if someone was saying, you know, maybe I apply to be like, what is the thing that you would say you would look
比如SOC 2、HIPAA以及所有其他ITAR（国际武器贸易条例）要求。所以我们在安全方面做得很好，或者说我们努力在安全方面做得很好，但显而易见，你永远不可能做到完美。是的。还有关于Shipyard的其他问题吗？是不是都涵盖了？没有，我的意思是，我想问的是——如果有人在考虑申请加入，你会看重他们对什么感兴趣？他们需要具备什么样的热情，才能成为完美的人选？
for them to be interested in? Like, what would they be passionate about that would make them a great fit? Yeah. I mean, high level efficiency is something that's important to them. Like understanding how broken our software development life, or maybe broken is not the right word, but slow and arduous. People that want to automate, people that want to help people move faster or companies move faster, which is a very cliche thing to say, but it's true. And then the other thing is, is like, look, we are in a critical path for all of our customers. They depend on us every day. So understanding that we're actually, you're going to have a lot of responsibility. You have to have a passion around DevOps to some degree, or at least making good software and
是的。高效率对他们来说是很重要的东西。比如理解我们糟糕的软件开发生命周期——或者说“糟糕”可能不是正确的词，但它是缓慢且艰难的。那些想要自动化、想要帮助人们或公司更快地向前发展的人，虽然这话听起来有点陈词滥调，但事实确实如此。另一件事是，看吧，我们处于所有客户的关键路径上，他们每天都依赖我们。所以要明白我们实际上——你将肩负重任。你必须在某种程度上对DevOps充满热情，或者至少对构建优质软件、
enabling product people and QA people to do that. That's kind of what we're looking for. But ultimately, you know, people that are curious and just want to make things is really what it comes down to because every day, you know, we're spending time on calls and planning and all these things. And the whole point is, is that our entire product is built off of customer feedback of being like, Oh, hey, like, this is great. But like, can I look at my logs and Datadog? Like, yeah, sure. So we build out this Datadog thing. And then all of a sudden, all of our customers want our Datadog integration, you know, just the whole point here is that we have some really cool at the precipice of, of software development getting a lot faster and
赋能产品和QA人员完成工作充满热情。这就是我们所寻找的。但归根结底，那些充满好奇心、只想把事情做出来的人，才是真正最重要的。因为每天，我们都要花时间开会、做规划以及处理各种事情，而核心要义在于：我们整个产品的构建都源于客户的反馈，比如：“哦，嘿，这太棒了，但我能在Datadog里查看我的日志吗？”“当然可以。”于是我们开发了这个Datadog功能。然后突然之间，我们所有的客户都想要我们的Datadog集成。所以，关键在于，我们正处于软件开发变得更加迅猛发展的浪潮之巅。
we're just trying to help push it along and so people that are a little empathetic to the pains of of other software development teams is another big thing we look for and remember or maybe don't remember i'm telling you we dog food shipyard with shipyard so we food shipyard with shipyard. So we build shipyard with shipyard. I was going to ask that actually. Yeah. So we are, we are definitely one of the larger users of shipyard. We're not actually the largest user anymore. We haven't been for six months or so, but for a long time, we were the largest user of shipyard from a builds perspective and the commit perspective and a business perspective. And so when we screw something up, yeah, we're going to know before everybody else. So we work hard to not do that, but also, you know, being able to react
我们只是想帮它一把，所以那些对其他软件开发团队的痛苦有点感同身受的人，是我们寻找的另一个重点。记住，或者可能不记得了，我跟你说过，我们用 Shipyard 养 Shipyard。所以我们用 Shipyard 构建 Shipyard。我本来想问这个来着。是的。所以我们确实是 Shipyard 的大用户之一。其实我们已经不是最大的用户了。大概有六个月左右不是了，但在很长一段时间里，从构建的角度、提交的角度以及业务的角度来看，我们都是 Shipyard 最大的用户。所以当我们搞砸了什么事情，是的，我们会比所有人更早知道。因此我们努力避免这种情况发生，不过同时，你知道，能够迅速反应
quickly and cool under pressure is another big trait that we like to have. I had a question, a bit of a non sequitur, but when you talked about being the biggest, the biggest consumer of shipyard, it kind of made spark this, which is, who do you go to when you want to acquire a customer? Because I feel like this is something I've often wondered, never really asked anybody. Clearly, you're interested in developers, but something like Shipyard, it's not like an IDE like Sublime where you can go straight to developers and say, hey, give me 15 bucks. And so you kind of want to target the sort of, let's say, VP of engineering or CTO or something. But then that person is so high level that it might be
并且在压力下保持冷静，这是我们希望具备的另一个重要特质。我有一个问题，有点扯远了，但当您提到自己是 Shipyard 最大、最大的消费者时，这让我突然想到了一个问题：当你想获取一个客户时，你去找谁？因为我觉得这是我经常想知道、但从没真正问过任何人的事情。显然，你对开发者感兴趣，但像 Shipyard 这样的东西，它不像 Sublime 那样的 IDE，你可以直接找到开发者说，嘿，给我 15 块钱。所以你基本上会去瞄准那种，比方说，工程副总裁或 CTO 之类的人。但随后那个人的层级太高了，可能
hard for them to grok what's going on. And so I feel like a lot of companies that have an enterprise tier, who do you go for? Who's your ideal person on LinkedIn when you want to try and acquire a new business? Yeah, that's a great question. So the term that we use in startup land, because I'm learning all this, yeah i am yeah i'm now the ceo is icp or initial customer profile is the term that we're supposed to use and nice that's yeah and that's something that that we're constantly iterating on and developing um so the way that shipyard has kind of put our company together is we had this very early with some early customers for the consulting side of the thing and then we raised some money and
很难让他真正理解发生了什么。所以我觉得很多拥有企业级产品的公司，你们会去找谁？当你想尝试获取一个新业务时，你在 LinkedIn 上寻找的理想人选是谁？是的，这是一个很好的问题。我们在初创公司圈子里用的术语，因为我正在学习所有这些，是的，我是，是的，我现在是 CEO，叫做 ICP 或初始客户平台，这是我们应该使用的术语，太棒了，是的，这也是我们一直在迭代和开发的东西。嗯，所以 Shipyard 组建我们公司的方式是，在咨询业务的早期，我们有一些早期客户，然后我们筹集了一些资金，并且
we've been super heads down building out a fully fledged platform so there was a lot of work that we didn't even realize stability is the most important thing features is then very important as well so we've been super heads down we got a bunch of great design partners and that's we use you know what's known as founder led sales for the most part there, there has been some other different top of funnel stuff there. And then we signed all our design partners and now we're figuring out the go-to-market and the ICP. But I think you hit the nail on the head where it is the VPs of engineering or the directors of engineering and whatnot. And the trick there is that the other departments
我们一直全神贯注地打造一个功能齐全的平台，所以有很多工作是我们甚至没有意识到的。稳定性是最重要的，功能然后也非常重要，所以我们一直全神贯注，我们找了一群优秀的设计合作伙伴，这就是我们主要使用所谓的创始人主导销售的地方，当然那里也有一些其他不同的人顶层漏斗的东西。然后我们签下了所有的设计合作伙伴，现在我们正在弄清楚市场进入策略和 ICP。但我觉得你切中要害了，那就是工程副总裁或工程总监之类的人。这里的诀窍在于，我们之前谈到的其他部门
that we talked about are kind of getting frustrated because they're not seeing features early enough. And you have to find the people that it's trickling back up to, but that are also the decision makers. I will say that most VPs of engineering and directors of engineering and even CTOs, for that matter,
开始感到沮丧，因为他们没有足够早地看到功能。你必须找到那些问题最终反馈到他们那里，但同时他们也是决策者的人。我要说的是，大多数工程副总裁、工程总监甚至 CTO，
have a pretty good understanding of environments. And it's just a matter of explaining oftentimes replacing half-baked solutions frankly or underbaked solutions maybe is a better way to put that but yeah so finding those people and that's what we're working on so you know it's one of the reasons why i'm on your podcast you know customers welcome but uh yeah totally yeah we're working on that and that's the stage of the reasons why I'm on your podcast. Customers welcome. Yeah, totally. Yeah, we're working on that. And that's the stage of the company that we're at. We're figuring out our go-to-market as we speak. We've had some early success and now it's just a matter of figuring out where to keep. Personally, I don't think LinkedIn is a good place because as a DevOps person or a
对环境都有相当不错的理解。这往往只是解释的问题，坦率地说，是取代半成熟的解决方案，或者说欠成熟的解决方案也许是更好的说法，但是的，所以找到那些人，这就是我们正在努力的事情，所以你知道，这也是我上你的播客的原因之一，你知道，欢迎客户，但嗯，完全是这样，是的，我们正在努力，这也是我们公司所处的阶段。我们正在边走边摸索我们的市场进入策略。我们取得了一些早期的成功，现在关键就是弄清楚在哪里保持。个人而言，我觉得 LinkedIn 不是个好地方，因为作为一个 DevOps 人员或者
VP of engineering, I never read my LinkedIn messages. I think I could change that at some point. Well, the free tier is interesting because you have potential for some bottom, I think that's what it's called, right? Bottom-up marketing. Basically, you put out the free tier, you get a coalition of developers to use it, and then now you have this, what's the term for this? Anyways, but you have a coalition of people at the company who are all in alignment there, and then they can motivate leadership.
工程副总裁，我从不读我的 LinkedIn 消息。我想我可以在某个时候改变这一点。嗯，免费层很有趣，因为你有潜力获得某种底层，我想这就是所谓的，对吧？自下而上的营销。基本上，你推出免费层，让一帮开发者使用它，然后现在你有了这个，这个叫什么来着？总之，你在公司里有一群人，他们在那里完全意见一致，然后他们可以激励领导层。
Right. It's called an internal champion. It sounds like you've done all these calls I've had with all leadership. Right. It's called an internal champion. It sounds like you've done all these calls I've had with all these VCs. It's awesome. No, we're actually a member of a... And if anyone's doing, especially developer-focused software platform, you should check them out and maybe, I don't know. But there's a VC fund slash incubator thing called Heavybit.
对。这叫内部拥护者。听起来你做过我和所有这些领导层之间的所有这些通话。对。这叫内部拥护者。听起来你做过我和所有这些 VC 之间的所有这些通话。太棒了。不，我们其实是一个……而且如果有人在做，特别是以开发者为中心的软件平台，你应该去看看他们，也许，我不知道。但有一个叫做 Heavybit 的 VC 基金兼孵化器机构。
And some of the best dev tool companies have gone through there. We're very fortunate to be in there. And they very much... What is it, Dane, one more time? I'm sorry, Heavybit? Heavybit. Okay, just for the... We'll put it in the show notes.
一些最优秀的开发工具公司都从那里走过。我们非常幸运能加入进去。他们非常……那是叫什么，Dane，再说一遍？不好意思，是 Heavybit？Heavybit。好的，为了……我们会把它写在节目简介里。
Sure. Well, okay, then you have to put all my investors in there. They'll get mad at me, but whatever. Okay, you just email us. We'll put it all in there. No, don't do that. This is not advertising for investors. But I will say that Heavybit has been instrumental in... if you can find don't put in the show notes but if
当然。好吧，好吧，那你就得把我所有的投资者都写进去了。他们会生我的气，不过随便啦。好吧，你直接给我们发邮件。我们会把所有这些都写进去。不，别那么做。这不是在为投资者做广告。但我必须说，Heavybit 在……如果你能找到，别写进节目简介里，但如果
you can find heavybit.com but they've been instrumental in kind of helping guide us through this whole bottoms up adoption thing where you reach out and you have a product that developers can use and that that's whose shipyard is for it's for developers that that don't want to focus all their time and devops people that don't want to focus all their time and DevOps people that don't want to focus all their time on these internal environments, but they still need them. And so you start from the ground up, you get these people bought in and then they're the ones
你能找到 heavybit.com，但他们在帮助指导我们完成整个自下而上的采用过程中发挥了关键作用，在这个过程中，你进行推广，并且你拥有一种开发者可以使用的产品，而这就是 Shipyard 的服务对象，它是为那些不想把所有时间都花在 DevOps 上的开发者准备的，以及那些不想把所有时间都花在 DevOps 上的 DevOps 人员准备的，他们不想把所有时间都花在这些内部环境上，但他们仍然需要这些环境。所以你从头开始，让这些人买单，然后他们就是那些
that bring it internally into their companies for the long tail thing. Cool. Thanks for explaining that. I was always curious. And yeah, I think you covered it really well. Great. Anything else I could give you my sort of answers to?
为了长尾效应将其引入公司内部的人。酷。谢谢你解释这些。我一直很好奇。是的，我觉得你解释得非常好。太棒了。我还能给你提供什么样的问题答案吗？
We could do all manner of opinions on world events, tech talk. No, no, no. I think this has been a great episode. I think this is an important topic. I learned stuff. So I'm thankful you came on. And I mean, it's great to see people out there building products to help developers and development just go better and faster. And so excited to have you continue to do that so that all the products we use are just going to be magically better. I mean, it's not magic, but it's true. We've seen some really cool numbers lately where we have one team in particular, I was on a call with them the other day, and they are doing 50% more tickets since they started using Shipyard
我们可以就世界事件、科技话题发表各种各样的看法。不，不，不。我觉得这是一期很棒的节目。我觉得这是一个重要的主题。我学到了东西。所以我很感谢你能来。而且，很高兴看到人们在那里构建产品来帮助开发者，让开发工作变得更好、更快。所以我很高兴你能继续这样做，这样我们使用的所有产品都会变得神奇般地更好。我的意思是，这并不是魔法，但确实如此。我们最近看到了一些非常酷的数据，我们有一个特别的团队，我前几天和他们通了电话，自从他们开始使用 Shipyard 以来，他们的 Ticket 产量增加了 50%
over the last like six months. It's unfair to say that's all Shipyard because I don't know, but I do know that that feedback loop is getting shorter. Tickets are getting done faster. So 50% velocity increase, that's pretty cool. We're still figuring out where that is. Other feedback we've had a lot is on the whole testing thing where the customer success team likes using Shipyard. They don't use Shipyard, but they love
在过去大约六个月里。把这全归功于 Shipyard 是不公平的，因为我不知道，但我确实知道那个反馈循环正在变短。Ticket 正在更快地完成。所以速度提升了 50%，这太酷了。我们仍在摸索那个具体情况。我们得到的另一个很多反馈是关于整个测试的事情，客户成功团队喜欢使用 Shipyard。他们不用 Shipyard，但他们喜欢
people using it because a lot fewer bugs are getting through because one of the problems with testing is that you get so many false positive tests that you just end up ignoring your tests and everyone does it everyone does it they might lie and pretend like they don't but everyone does it but if you can test earlier and transfer the ownership of that failing test earlier on the cycle then all of a, those tests become much more reliable. And ultimately, testing, unit testing, end-to-end testing, it's really about confidence. You're never going to be perfect, but it's like, as a developer, am I confident that I can get this out the door and move faster? And the end result is that customer success people are dealing with a lot less tickets. So that's another place that is a very good thing. And
人们使用它，因为通过的 Bug 少了很多，因为测试的问题之一是你会得到如此多的误报测试，以至于你最后直接忽略了你的测试，每个人都这样做，每个人都这样做，他们可能会撒谎假装他们不这样，但每个人都这样做。但如果你能更早地进行测试，并在周期的更早期转移失败测试的所有权，那么所有这些测试就会变得更加可靠。归根结底，测试，单元测试，端到端测试，其实都是关于信心的。你永远不可能做到完美，但这就像是，作为一个开发者，我是否有信心把这个东西推向市场并走得更快？其最终结果是，客户成功人员需要处理的 Ticket 少了很多。所以这也是一个非常好的地方，并且
then the last one, just to pitch Shipyard, is cost control, because people do have environments, but they just get left on for months at a time. And so we monitor the environments, we keep them on when you're using them, we turn them off when you're not. And remember, this is container, so it's very quick to turn these things back on. You just click a button, and then you stop using it, it goes down. So cost control very quick to turn these things back on you just click a button and then you stop using it goes down so cost control security all these things this is what shipyard is oh one thing i did not plug i forgot to plug i am a co-host of a podcast called cube list sorry if that's i hope it's okay to no go for it yeah yeah totally so yeah so cube list is very cncf kubernetes focus but that's cubelist.com and you can check it out.
最后一个，顺便宣传一下 Shipyard，就是成本控制，因为人们确实有环境，但它们常常一连几个月都被开着。所以我们监控环境，在你使用时让它们保持开启，不用时将它们关闭。记住，这是容器，所以重新开启这些东西非常快。你只需点一下按钮，然后你不用了，它就关闭了。所以成本控制，重新开启这些东西非常快，你只需点一下按钮，然后你不用了，它就关闭了。所以成本控制、安全性，所有这些，这就是 Shipyard。哦，还有一件事我没宣传，我忘了宣传，我是个播客的联合主持人，叫做 Cube list，抱歉，如果这……我希望这可以……不，去吧，是的，是的，完全可以。所以，是的，Cube list 非常专注于 CNCF Kubernetes，网址是 cubelist.com，你可以去看看。
I co-host that with Mark, the CTO from Replicated. There's also a newsletter. But in general, our goal right now is to try and just get as much best practices out there because we've just hurt ourselves
我和 Replicated 的 CTO Mark 一起共同主持。还有一个新闻简报。但总的来说，我们现在的目标是试着尽可能多地分享最佳实践，因为我们自己
and shot ourselves in the foot so much. Bringing it back to the experience thing. You know, I don't know everything, but I know a lot of mistakes I've made over the years, especially in the software development lifecycle. And so we're trying to help fix as many of those as possible man your episode list has pictures and everything like i don't know man
已经受够了伤，搬起石头砸了自己的脚太多次了。回到经验这个话题上来。你知道，我不是无所不知，但我知道这些年来我犯过很多错误，尤其是在软件开发生命周期中。所以我们正试图尽力修复尽可能多的这类问题。天哪，你的节目列表里还有图片什么的，我不知道，老兄，
i think i take it backward i have to edit that out like you're making us look bad over here oh man we got scooped i'm just teasing just teasing no it's great i i don't do it i don't do it it's the the mark and the replicated guys are great and actually again for some reason heavy bit is great as well they help us we're part of their catalog of podcasts and stuff like that but jason we need vcs man we need vcs it's official all right i'll let me know i'll have it wait but shipyard.build is the point of the whole thing. So everyone. So actually one thing, if we have a lot of folks in college, you know, I looked at shipyard.build earlier today and, you know, a college kid looks at $500 a month and says, you know,
我觉得我得倒退一下，我得把那段剪掉，听着你把我们衬托得很逊啊，哦天哪，我们被抢先了，我开玩笑呢，开玩笑呢，不，这很棒，我没做这个，我没做，Mark 和 Replicated 的那些家伙太棒了，而且实际上，不知为何 Heavy bit 也很棒，他们帮助我们，我们是他们播客目录等的一部分，但是 Jason，我们需要 VC 啊，老兄，我们需要 VC。这是官方的，好吧，让我知道，我稍等……但 Shipyard.build 才是整个事情的关键。所以每个人。所以实际上有一件事，如果我们有很多在校大学生，你知道，我今天早些时候看了一下 Shipyard.build，你知道，一个大学生看到一个月 500 美元就会说，你知道，
I just can't do that. Right. So, so I know the free tier is coming. So should folks wait for that? Should they should do an email? If someone, if someone really wants to try shipyard, what's the next step for them? Like someone in college? So right now we have a free trial
我实在负担不起。对吧。所以，我知道免费层快推出了。那么大家应该等那个吗？他们应该发邮件吗？如果有人，如果有人真的想尝试 Shipyard，他们的下一步是什么？比如一个大学生？所以现在我们有一个免费试用期，
and you get the full experience for 30 days. If you're in college and you want to try it out, sign up for that. If we see you have good usage and you reach out, we'll make sure that you don't. We'll make sure that we get you early access to the free tier. Let's call it that, but probably a little bit even better than that.
你可以获得 30 天的完整体验。如果你是一名大学生并且想尝试一下，注册那个就行。如果我们看到你的使用情况很好并且你主动联系我们，我们会确保你不会。我们会确保让你尽早访问免费层。我们就这么叫它吧，不过可能比那个还要稍微好一点。我们希望
We want everyone using this. We want everyone learning. But the thing to keep in mind also is that if you're a college student that's just using it for yourself, I'm happy for you guys to do that. But really, it's for the college students that are working on a project with multiple people that there's a lot of value there. So all you need is a GitHub account, which is free, and sign up and reach out.
每个人都使用这个。我们希望每个人都在学习。但也要记住的是，如果你是一个只是自己使用的大学生，我很高兴你们这样做。但实际上，它是为那些与多个人合作项目的大学生准备的，那里有很大的价值。所以你只需要一个 GitHub 账户，它是免费的，然后注册并联系我们。
And yeah, I think info at shipyard.build is the best way to do that. But there's information in the console. And also kick the tires. Like you find bugs, you find stuff like that. We're happy to have you in there and we'll find a way to let you keep access. Cool, yeah.
是的，我觉得 info@shipyard.build 是最好的联系方式。但在控制台中也有相关信息。另外还可以去试用一下。如果你发现了 Bug，发现了诸如此类的事情。我们很高兴你能加入进来，我们会想办法让你继续拥有访问权限。酷，是的。
I mean, one thing that i really like you know if i had to do my phd over again i would well i would cry and i would i would lose a lot of sleep and a lot of hair but but once i've gotten over the trauma i would i would use a lot more ci cd and like dev tools because i found that near the end of my phd you know i had to get this journal paper done and i needed to gather a lot of results. And especially at the end of your PhD, you're not really trying to invent another new thing. You're trying to write a paper, like survey kind of papers that try your method 2000 different times and have a lot of nice graphs and data and all of that. And the bad design decisions that I
我的意思是，有一件事我真的很喜欢，你知道，如果让我重新读博，我会……好吧，我会哭，我会失眠，掉很多头发，但一旦我熬过了创伤，我会使用更多的 CI/CD 和开发工具，因为我发现在我博士快结束时，你知道，我必须完成这篇期刊论文，我需要收集大量的研究结果。尤其是当你的博士生涯接近尾声时，你其实不是在试图发明另一个新东西。你是在试着写一篇论文，比如那种调查类的论文，尝试你的方法 2000 次，并有很多漂亮的图表、数据以及所有这些。而那些糟糕的设计决策，我
made, you know, in the first level were really kind of catching up with me. And I think that having a, you know, having a tool like Shipyard would have helped, you know, kind of keep some of that technical debt under control. So yeah, if you're doing a doctorate or, you know, if you're working in a lab or even like a senior design project, you know, anything that's involved you and several other people, I think that it could be great to, you know, get on tools like this. Yeah. That's, I mean, I wish there was some CIC stuff back then, but yeah, it becomes a, yeah, it becomes, it becomes kind of, it's become standard practice to protect you from yourself. And also just, I mean, the whole reason we program is
在第一阶段作出的，真的开始追着我付代价了。我觉得拥有一个，你知道，拥有像 Shipyard 这样的工具本来可以帮助，你知道，控制住部分技术债。所以，是的，如果你在攻读博士学位，或者，你知道，如果你在一个实验室工作，甚至像是一个高级设计项目，你知道，任何涉及你和其他几个人的事情，我觉得使用这样的工具会很棒。是的。那是，我的意思是，我希望当时能有一些 CIC 的东西，但是的，它变成了一个，是的，它变成了一种，它已经成为保护你免受自身伤害的标准做法。而且，我的意思是，我们编程的全部原因
because we had to type the same thing twice and we're like because we had to type the same thing twice. And we're like, I can't type the same thing twice. I need to spend two days writing something to do that for me. Stop, stop, stop. No, no. My heart's getting torn asunder here. Well, I mean, hey, we all went to computer science school. Wait, I have a question for you.
是因为我们不得不把同样的事情敲两遍，然后我们觉得……因为我们不得不把同样的事情敲两遍。然后我们觉得，我不能敲两遍同样的事情。我需要花两天时间写点东西来替我做这件事。停，停，停。不，不。我的心在这里都要碎了。好吧，我的意思是，嘿，我们都上过计算机科学学校。等等，我有个问题要问你。
What was your PhD in? Sorry, I just didn't know. Oh, yeah. My PhD was this crazy idea of like trying to play Go with the neural networks. It'll never work. It'll never take off. I did. My Excel-based neural net was not a PhD. It was a class that I took, but it was to play Go. Oh, very cool. Yeah. Similarly, you know, my Go rating is something like 27 Co or something. So I was like, well, this can't stand. So I got to create a computer to actually play good Go for me.
你的博士学位是什么专业的？抱歉，我刚刚不知道。哦，是的。我的博士学位是那个疯狂的想法，就是尝试用神经网络来下围棋。这永远不会成功。这永远不会流行。我做过。我那个基于 Excel 的神经网络不是博士论文。那是我上过的一门课，但它是用来下围棋的。哦，非常酷。是的。同样，你知道，我的围棋段位大约是 27 段还是什么的。所以我当时就想，嗯，这可不行，我得造一台电脑来真正帮我下好围棋。
And you literally did a PhD on it. Yeah, pretty much. That's cool. That's super cool. All right. Well, I could talk to you about this stuff a bunch. We should have. Yeah, I'm happy to come on your show and talk about computer Go, definitely.
而你真的就此写了一篇博士论文。是的，差不多吧。太酷了。这太酷了。好吧。嗯，我可以和你聊一聊这些事情。我们应该……是的，我很乐意上你的节目聊聊计算机围棋，绝对的。
Yeah, that would be great. Yeah, absolute pleasure yeah thanks for coming on benji i appreciate this has been a great episode and thank you everyone for tuning in and sticking with us every episode and engaging with us as we learn and explore and uh we should have a tagline dang it that sounded like it was almost cool learn and explore with Jason and Patrick. All right. Till next time.
是的，那太棒了。是的，非常荣幸，谢谢你来参加，Benji，我很感激，这是一期很棒的节目，谢谢所有收听并一直陪伴我们、在我们的学习和探索中与我们互动的每个人，呃，我们应该想个标语，该死，听起来几乎很酷。与 Jason 和 Patrick 一起学习和探索。好的。直到下次再见。
Thank you everyone so much for, for supporting us on Patreon and on, on audible. We really appreciate your time and, you know, look forward to the next episode. Thanks everybody. music by eric parndollar programming throwdown is distributed under a creative commons attribution share alike 2.0 license you're free to share copy distribute transmit the work to remix adapt the work but you must provide an attribution to to Patrick and I and share alike in time There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
非常感谢大家在 Patreon 和 Audible 上对我们的支持。我们非常感谢大家的时间，并且，你知道，期待下一期节目。谢谢大家。音乐由 Eric Parndollar 提供。Programming Throwdown 在知识共享署名-相同方式共享 2.0 协议下发布。你可以自由分享、复制、分发、传输该作品，可以改编作品，但你必须对我和 Patrick 进行署名，并采用相同方式共享。目前本期节目还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。